Hello!
Oh my god, what was the wrong one?
Whoops!
I picked the wrong one.
Oh, wow.
Is it because of the game?
Oh man, okay, give me a sec.
Is this still compiling shaders?
Okay, we're definitely going to adjust the settings for this later.
Okay, anyway.
Okay, when I tab out...
Okay, yeah, I'll adjust this later.
I have the game booted up, but...
The shadings have been compiled!
The shaders have been compiled.
But I want to be here because I just want to make, like, you know, rip a bandit up, make a quick statement again.
Because of, like, you know, it's crazy about so much stuff coming out and everything.
So for those who are wondering, I sort of... I did know.
I want everyone to go support Mint tomorrow as well because it will be her fifth year anniversary.
And she's been going through a lot.
I did know about that she got signed to be Shoujo for a while.
I think, like, around the time she got signed, I didn't know about it.
But I didn't pry too much details about, like, what was going on and everything.
And, you know, I just let her tell me stuff, like, if she wanted to.
Or, like, you know, I try not to pry too much.
So I didn't know how bad it was.
Because I just knew, like, the surface level details.
And Mint and I were actually supposed to do something together.
We had, like, a project together.
But we pushed it back and tabled it.
It was, like, in planning stages.
Not like we, like, made stuff for it already or everything.
It was just planning stages and stuff.
But we pushed it back and tabled it.
Because she wanted to focus her energy on her debut for this year.
And I was, like...
And then, like, you know, months sort of passed.
And I was, like, oh, aren't you supposed to debut and be Shoujo?
And she was, like, yeah, but he got pushed back.
And I didn't know reasoning.
I didn't pry about it.
And I was just...
Back then, I was, like, oh, that's great.
More time to prepare, you know?
I was, like, oh, that's cool.
You get more time to prepare for your debut.
Like, yeah, because I didn't know what was going on.
I was, like, at least you get to have a better debut and everything.
Like,
you know, in hindsight.
Maybe I...
Now that I know, in hindsight.
Um, also, I just, uh...
Yeah, I was very clueless.
Um...
Uh...
But I didn't want to, like, address this situation...
This thing, because of, like, there were so many, like, rumors and stuff going around.
But for those who were wondering...
No, I was never approached about...
By B-Shojo.
I didn't realize how big the rabbit hole was.
And I'm finding out so much information at the same time as you guys right now.
And, um...
Uh, no VTuber company wanted me or, like, gave me an offer.
Or, like, approached me to help me after, you know, I got fired.
And got thrown into being indie.
Um, and I think, like, a lot of people forgot that, like...
I was basically, like, super taboo and radioactive.
And also controversial.
And I...
Uh, so, yeah.
No, I didn't...
I didn't get any offers.
There was no poaching when it comes to me.
Um...
So I just wanted...
Because I saw somebody be like, oh, it's the most...
I was like, well, that would be news for me.
Ha ha ha ha!
Um...
So I just want to say that in case there's, like, rumors that, like, wow, I can't believe...
He showed you I approached, you know, all of these people.
And I was like, no, no, not me.
I was not involved in anything.
Like...
Ha ha ha!
Ha ha!
Um...
And...
Okay, I'm sorry.
It makes you feel like I'm making this about myself.
But I just wanted people to know that I wasn't contacted by an agency or any agency to join them after, you know, I got fired.
But, like, you know, the past is the past.
I mostly moved on from it.
And, like, you know, we gotta focus on the current and help the people that need it now.
So, like, it did give me, like, PTSD and sort of reopened some memories and trauma.
So, like, I guess that's why I'm, like, reacting like this right now.
Ha ha ha!
Like, I'm all over the place emotionally, um, about it.
And, yeah, I know, uh, just when you guys...
Not even pre-indie was I approached.
Because I saw people were, like, oh, man, they contacted every...
Not, not, no, no.
There's...
I feel like there were some of us that wasn't...
Just so you guys know, some of us...
Oh, I don't know if all...
Maybe it was just me.
I don't know.
But I wasn't approached even pre-indie.
But now I'm, like, finding out...
I'm, like...
I'm, like, I found out, like, so many other people did.
And, you know, like, that gift was, like, you guys get paid?
Like, like...
Ha ha ha ha!
I was so...
Like, that's how I was, like...
I was, like, wait, you guys got poached?
Like...
Ha ha ha ha!
I was just, like...
So, like, that was mean...
Like, that was my...
Like, not my reaction.
But I was, like, just thinking about that gift when I found out.
Like, wait, how many people did they approach, like, pre-indie?
I was, like, so...
I was, like, wait, what?
Like, how many people got approached?
But please support those who were affected with the V Shoujo collapse.
I know the transition period would be very hard, especially being thrust into uncertainty and all the projects and things you were looking forward to just disappearing and stuff.
I had a few of the stuff in the works at that time that I would never see the light of day after countless hours and days and weeks working on them and I even had an injury to produce one of the things.
So I understand the grief that they're going through.
And it's just really sad because no one deserves to experience that and I really hope they all find a place and are able to recover.
You know, my story is done.
Like, this is their story.
And we need to focus on the now and hearing their voice and all of this.
So yeah, like, please support everyone.
Like I said, Mint's anniversary is tomorrow.
And I hear the girls that, you know, they're supposed to debut right after Mint.
It was the monster girl.
Jen is also doing collabs.
So yeah, please support the previous talents and also the ones that, you know, came before them and the ones that were supposed to debut.
As well.
So yeah, support all of them.
Uh, they, uh, really need it during, like, this time.
So, uh, but yeah, um, um, I assume like, you know, like, uh, so hard to talk about this.
It is like, you know, when I, like, I didn't do much work the last two days because it just, like, it just felt like deja vu.
Like looking at it as, I don't know.
I'm like looking at it in the sidelines.
I mean, like, I can't believe this is sort of like, you know, another VTuber Armageddon again.
And like, it's just, it's just so, I, I really feel for them.
Um, and like, oh my gosh.
When I was reading that statement about how, what's the word?
I was reading, like, a recount of, like, what, like, people were doing and stuff to pit people against each other and everything.
Like, that was like, oh my gosh.
That felt like deja vu.
I don't know if I can say deja vu.
But like, I felt that.
Because like, I think also the reason why, like, um, like, you know, during that time for me, it was, a lot of stuff was going on.
And, uh, like I said, like, you know, nobody really wanted, like, professionally wise, no one really wanted to, like, touch me, you know?
And also, like, um, there was a lot of false rumors and narratives being spread about me behind the scenes.
And I remember someone approaching me about some of the false rumors.
And I had to provide them, like, proof and actual, like, personal documents to show that it was false.
And it was very crazy.
Like, some of the malicious stuff that was, like, spread about me that weren't even true.
That was said about me behind my back and spread around during that time.
And, um, it's also why I kept to myself for so long and not really done much interacting with new people.
Because, like, you know, who knows what people were saying behind my back and, um, about me.
And then that they, like, oh, these people might secretly hate me or had this false image of me.
Because, like, of all the rumors going around at that time.
And I already had really bad trust issues.
So at a point I was very, like, you know, fucking paranoid.
I was, like, super paranoid at that time.
I was, like, I was like, oh, I can't trust anyone.
So, like, I'm super thankful to the people that still want to do things with me.
And interact with me.
And never, like, believed in the false rumors.
And that's why I'm really happy to see, like, such a big community there.
Supporting all these girls.
Um, and guy.
One guy.
I saw, like, Kuro's tweets.
Like, I'm the first and last v-shoujo male that they've ever hired.
But supporting all those girls plus one guy.
And, yeah.
And then, like, you know, having people approach me to hear my story after being told.
Even, like, there's, like, moments where they were, like, told to not interact with Doki.
Like, don't interact with her.
Um, because, like, these false narratives are spread about me.
And, um, and then, like, you know, they were willing to listen to, like, my side of the story.
And, uh, and then, you know, when they approached me about it, I usually provided proof that the rumors were false.
You know?
And then, like, at one point, though, the brain worms started attacking.
And I was, like, I won't say, like, it was not resentful.
But I felt, like, super worthless for, like, not being good enough to even be considered.
Or, like, helped.
Or, like, you know, even followed on Twitter.
Like, I was very jealous at that time.
It was, like, definitely hard since I had to, like, build my own thing up for a year.
And there was a lot of, like, you know, setbacks and how messy everything was.
Like, you know, merch.
And I made a lot of mistakes trying to build my own thing.
And it was very hard because at first, when I started trying to rebuild everything, like, it was just me and, like, a very small, like, like, maybe, like, one to two people.
Like, you know, one, two to three people helping me try to build everything from the ground up.
I didn't have, like, you know, a lot of help back then.
Um, just starting it.
But then, like, it got better and better, like, as things go on.
And, you know, we're finally, you know, almost in the clear.
And I can sort of see the light now.
But for those who are like, oh, just go indie.
It's very hard.
When you have, like, the structure.
When you have the structure and safety, the safety net of, like, a company, and then you transition to indie, it's incredibly hard to do something like that.
It's a huge jump.
Especially when you have to do stuff from the ground up.
And it's not, it's like, it depends on what kind of indie you want to be.
Like, obviously, like, corporal, like, corporal VTubers, they have a lot more.
Like, it's not just streaming.
There's a lot more things going into it.
Um, you know, there's, like, events, merchandising, sponsors, branding, everything like that.
And to try and replicate that as an indie is very difficult.
Um, like, trying to sell yourself by yourself.
Especially as an individual.
You're not selling, like, a brand image.
Because, like, that's the thing.
When you're in a company, you're selling, like, a group of people.
But now that you're an individual, you have to sell yourself.
So you have to be like, no, no.
Pick me.
Even though I'm an individual, you should pick me.
And that's very hard to do.
Um, it's incredibly hard.
This is why I've been, I'll tell you this now.
I've been more busy as an indie than I've ever been as, um, when I was in a company.
Um, and even then, this is why you don't see much events from me these days.
Because I've been doing more so behind the scenes work than I have been focused.
Because, okay, the reason why I had so many events back then was because I was so fucking bored.
Like, I had no other things to do.
Um, you know, I wasn't getting, like, you know, I wasn't really getting sponsors or, like, you know, stuff I should do for the company.
At that time, everything I did back then was, like, stuff I wanted, like, I had nothing to do.
Like, so then I did these events because I was, like, um, I wanna say bored.
Okay, maybe bored is the wrong word to pick.
But, like, um, there was just, like, nothing.
Like, I could just stream or I could do something, you know, do something worthwhile instead of just, like, coasting and stuff.
Um, I just had, yeah, um, I had a very open schedule.
Yeah, um, so, yeah, I had a lot of ambition, too.
But now that I am in indie, uh, now that I'm indie, there's so many other things I have to do behind the scenes.
Which prevents me from actually doing, you know, organizing events and stuff.
Because, like, there's, you know, I need to market myself.
Um, where I have to market myself and stuff like that.
So, for those who are like, oh, just start it, just, you know, start a company.
Or, like, indie's not that bad.
Oh my gosh, it's so hard.
But to be fair, it depends on what kind of streamer you wanna be.
And for me, in terms of, like, what I wanna be as a streamer, I have a lot of ambition.
And I have a lot of, like, ideas and things I really wanna do.
Because I don't want to just stream.
I wanna, like, do more than that.
I have a lot of, like, crazy ideas.
I wanna put out a bit forth.
Um, um, and, and that's why, like, um, uh, that's why, like, for me, I'm always busy almost every day because of it.
Like, I have, like, a huge list of tasks that I have to follow and everything.
And, like, a lot of things to reply to and stuff like that.
So, um, so, like, you have to be a workaholic to really, like, do the stuff I'm currently doing.
Um, just because, like, uh, just because, you know, like, I just like doing all these things.
Because I have, I guess I have a lot of ambition and things.
So, um, it's very understandable why people wanna choose the corporate route.
Because, you know, being here by yourself, it's just a whole different step into, like, it's just a lot.
It's, it's, it is really a lot.
And even then, like, I've cried several times before about how much work I had to do to, um, like, throughout this journey and everything.
And, um, that's why, like, I really feel for these girls because, like, they never, you know, they were never, they never anticipated this.
Sorry, girls plus one guy.
Uh, I'm sorry, Kuro.
Yeah, it's a lot of networking, too.
Because, you know, the company can help you do the networking.
But, uh, um, um, um, but then you have to do your own networking now.
Um, but yeah, so, the one guide.
Uh, uh, but yeah, like I said, like, for those, these girls, you know, they're, like, thrust into, basically, being thrust into being indie again.
And that's, that's a, a big, you know, what's the word?
That's, like, a huge, they, they were not expecting this out of nowhere.
Like, not, I mean, I won't say out of nowhere.
They just, you know, I felt like maybe they didn't have a lot of time to just be thrust into that.
Um, it was such a huge shock and everything.
Yeah, the blind side of all that.
Yeah.
So, I understand.
So, that's why I would love if everybody showed them lots of love.
Um, and appreciation.
And, you know, give them the support to adjust to being an indie.
Um, or, like, transition, maybe they'll be able to, you know, transition to another company.
Or, um, transition into being a indie and everything.
So, yeah, I just want to say, I just want to make that statement.
Um, because, like, it did, it did open, like, a lot of, like, PTSD about that.
So, I really feel for everybody that's going through this right now.
Um, and, oh my gosh, sorry, I'm making this too much about, like, myself and stuff.
But, it's just, like, based off, like, my own experiences, I could, like, sort of feel for them a lot.
Um, so, yeah, support them.
Um, check out Min's Anniversary Stream tomorrow.
Um, donate to the Immune Deficiency Foundation, the Tiltify for that.
Um, check out the girls.
Apparently, they're doing a collab, what could have been.
Um, and, uh, uh, yeah, I emphasize, I empathize with them a lot.
So, I do hope that they don't, the girls that did get in won't stop dreaming.
Um, and, you know, um, I hope they make it.
Um, I hope they find, you know, the audience, uh, through this, be able to find a bigger audience and a bigger support community and everything.
Um, yeah, the charity reached a million dollars.
That's actually, like, double of what, like, you know, what the initial goal, like, well, I mean, the initial goal is, like, $10,000.
But, you know, I mean, it was double of what, um, was stolen.
So, uh, um, so, yeah, huge, like, huge congratulations to everybody.
Um, um, and, uh, I hope that, uh, I hope, you know, everybody lands on their feet and everyone's, you know, everyone is able to achieve what they want to achieve in the future without needing, uh, Shoujo and everything.
Oh, man, that's, like, I just wanted to make this extra statement.
Well, my original intent was to be, like, no, I was never approached.
Because I, I, it was so weird seeing that around.
I just, I don't know.
I just don't like false narratives about me going around.
So, I just wanted to, like, be very clear about that.
It's like, wow, like, Doki, I can't, I can't believe Doki might, like, was also, like, approached to be, like, they tried to poach Doki, too, because they were trying to, they recruited men.
So, they must have been trying to poach Doki.
So, I was like, no, like, if anything, I got zero offers from anyone.
Like, it was very rough down there when I got fired.
Like, I really did appreciate, like, all the...
Um, I really appreciate, uh, that, uh, um, that, like, uh, a lot of companies, uh, not VTuber, not agencies or VTuber companies, but, like, you know, like, companies, like, you know, Hyatt, Gamersupps, um, and, you know, U2s, Nendroid, they were willing to work with me as an individual.
Um, as an individual as well.
Like, they, they extended their hand.
They're like, we don't care, like, we don't care about what's going on with you right now.
Like, like, we want to, you know, work with you.
And I really appreciate that.
So, I hope that all the other girls, um, are able to have, like, similar experiences as well with, um, with working with, like, not needing a company to work with these brands.
Because I always thought that I needed a company to work with these brands, but obviously, like, now, um, now I know, like, you don't need a company for that.
You can get these brands yourself without needing a corporate backing.
Um, it is a lot harder, though, because, you know, you can't use a company lawyer.
You have to use your own lawyer.
And even then, like, you know, lawyers are expensive and stuff like that.
So, that's, like, some of the biggest challenges that, like, in terms of, like, finding the right lawyer to look through contracts and stuff.
Because I made some mistakes in my first few initial contracts.
And, um, from my own experience, I didn't make a few, like, mistakes for my initial contracts.
Just because I didn't, like, read it fully and stuff.
Um, I didn't, like, read it fully.
I was just, like, signed.
You know?
But, like, now, now, you know, I have more experience with it.
My, I, um, I actually, okay, the first few contracts I signed, I didn't have a lawyer read it.
So, because I was just, like, I was just so happy, you know?
I got, like, offers and everything.
I was just, like, yay!
Sign my name!
I, so, like I said, I learned all of this the hard way.
But, like, obviously, the more I'm, the more I learn, the more, like, the more, the more, I got a lawyer.
I have a lawyer looking through all my contracts now.
Like, they wouldn't be, you don't understand.
Like, I just desperately wanted to be me.
I just, I, you don't understand.
Back then, I just wanted someone to want me.
You don't, I had nothing.
Like, if you guys remember before then, in the before times, like, I barely got anything.
So, like, so, so, I mean, I won't say I barely got anything.
But, like, in comparison, I felt like I was, like, not, like, I was just, like, um, what's the way?
I felt like I had to try so hard to get one thing back then.
And so, like, um, to even get, like, just one thing, I felt like I had to try so hard.
Um, and, um, so then, like, you know, when I got fired, I was just like, I was like, oh my god.
Like, I was like, you want me?
Like, I was like, oh my god, you want me to advertise your product?
Holy shit.
I was just like, whoa!
Um, but yeah, I, I do hope, uh, I do hope, like, like, all these, all the girls, plus one guy, uh, I'm sorry, I shouldn't keep music doing that gym.
I, it's just too easy.
Uh, Be able to, you know, get on your feet, um, and recover, and they have so much support right now, but I just, I hope that everyone is able to get all the support and love, um, that, um, they need at the moment.
So, yeah, check, check all the girls out.
Plus Girl.
And, you know, support them during the transition.
And your friend Steve.
Steve.
Yeah, anyway, that's the statement I wanted to make.
Sorry.
I don't want people to think I'm making it about me.
I'm sorry.
It gave me, like, a lot.
Like I said, it gave me, like, when, like, all this, like, unfolded, I was just, it reopened, like, some wounds for myself.
Because, like, not wounds, like, trauma from what happened to me, too.
So, it just felt like, so I'm, like, so emotional about all of this.
Like, the PTSD and everything.
So, like, but my story is done.
It's done.
We closed.
The book on that.
Yeah, like, yeah, it's the flashbacks.
Yeah.
But, yes, let's play!
Wu-Chang Fallen Feathers.
I have been looking forward to this game for a while.
I was, I forgot that this game came out this month.
Like, it felt like it came out so fast.
Like, I legitimately, I felt like I watched the trailer for this so recently.
And then it's, like, out now.
And, yeah, I heard people thought, say this game is really good.
For those who don't know, it is, um, it's, so, it's basically an RPG Souls-like.
Um, but it's based off of, yes, it is from a Chinese developer.
Because it's based off of Chinese history and, uh, folklore.
So, um, so if you guys know, like, Wu-Kan, it's, I don't know if it's, like, I think it's, like, sort of similar.
Um, but instead of playing as a monkey, you get to play as a hot girl.
Uh, yeah, I saw some Wu-Kan, but hot girls are hot women.
And they're, uh, so instead of my monkey, it's, uh, hot woman.
Um, and I, it looks, the trailer looked really good.
And I like that it was based off of, like, uh, folk, like, you know, uh, Chinese folklore mythology.
Which I'm a sucker for, because I love, um, I love Chinese folklore.
As someone, like, grew up with, like, stories and, like, TV shows and movies about it.
And I read, I love mythology in general.
I love reading different types of mythologies.
Like, not just China, but, like, from all around the world.
But I feel like, you know, it's been so long since we had, like, games.
Like, I feel like we never really had games based off of Chinese folklore and mythology and history.
Other than, like, you know, we have three kingdoms that's just based off of the three kingdoms.
But, like, I eat that shit every day.
Like, I, I love the three kingdoms.
I love that they, they, I, I don't care if Dynasty Warriors, like, rehash the story over and over again.
I want to see this story over and over again.
And, like, by the way, what I meant, like, I meant, like, I, I eat that, that up.
Like, I don't mean, like, shit as in bad, but as in, like, I, I, it's like, um, it's just a slang.
So I'm just like, yum yum yum.
I love this so much.
I don't mean it's bad.
I meant as in like, I love it so much that I will consume it daily.
Also, give me a sec.
My precooked meals are coming.
Open the door for them.
Let me open the door for my precooked meal.
Alright, there you go.
But like... I'll consume that content.
I love... I love Dynasty Warriors.
I love the Three Kingdom history.
Yum yum yum yum yum.
I love it so much.
But like, we only... when it comes to like, you know, AAA gaming and gaming in general...
Like, you know, gaming in general, we don't really get a lot of Chinese history games.
Like, games based off China's history other than the Three Kingdoms.
Because, you know, everyone knows about the Three... Like, the Three Kingdoms is like...
It's like such a... Um, you know, like, based off of Romance of the Three Kingdom, which I also love...
Like I said, I love the era of the Three Kingdoms.
So I consume... I've like, you know, read lots of...
I've read the original books.
I've visited the tombs and everything of Lu Bei.
I visited Lube's tomb.
I've watched so many movies based off the Three Kingdoms and everything.
And yeah, it's like basically like, you know, the Three Kingdoms is sort of like... I guess you'd say the Three Kingdoms is sort of like King Arthur.
But yeah, but a lot of games tend to just follow the Three Kingdoms.
And there's a lot of interesting points and periods in Chinese history.
So it's really nice to see like... it's nice to see the... you know, like them going through a different era.
And also integrating, you know, Chinese mythology and Chinese folklore into, you know, into like the game as well.
So I'm really looking forward to it.
I will say that they did give me an early access key.
I didn't play it at all, even though I did get a free early access key.
Because they were like, you can't stream it unless until launch day.
So I was like, what's the point, you know?
Like, you can play it off stream and like make a video about it before the launch day.
But I was like, I'm gonna stream it, you know?
Yeah, I was like, I was like, but I don't want to stream it.
So I waited until today to stream the game.
Yeah, like, you know, I want to like react to it like blindly with all of you.
Um, uh, but yeah, anyway, I'm looking forward to it.
Let's go check it out.
bup, bup, bup, bup, bup, bup.
Alright.
d d d d d d d d d d d d d d here we go.
I don't think it will compile shaders again, because I compiled it, uh, off stream.
So we'll see.
I know that I definitely have to adjust the graphics though.
Because, uh, I could tell that it's gonna be intensive.
Wait, nice hoodie.
Thank you.
I saw in the trailer there's a half-naked bird lady, so I figured I should match it as well.
Not the half-naked part, the bird lady part.
Just so you guys know.
Not the half-naked part.
Okay, that should be good.
Brightness.
This should be fun.
Alright.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba!
Oh, there's a photosensitive seizure warning.
Okay.
Wait, where- Oh, I didn't get to read it.
The story is a work of fiction.
Any resemblance between the character, groups, events, language, or other elements within the work?
And you're like, I'm purely coincidental.
No.
They're real to me.
But they're real to me.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Free.
I love free stuff.
Alright.
Uh... Tutorial on.
I don't like... I don't like stream vibration.
Streamer mode?
Blood, gore from game, and adjust certain... You know what?
Let's...
If anything, they just take my monetization.
Okay, guys?
I'm not that scared.
I... My final words before my channel gets deleted.
Look, look.
See?
It just says, you know, disables blood, gore, and adjust certain co- Okay, let's... Let's test bait.
Let's test it.
I feel risky today.
Um... By the way, remember when I told you guys that, um... Um...
I forgot to, like, put a music credit in my description.
And then, like, my appeal got rejected.
And I had, like, one last chance to do it.
Before, uh... Before, like... If it gets rejected again, they'll put an actual strike on my channel.
Well, I got a... Um... That... The gambling paid off, because I...
Got a reply back, and they're like, we whitelisted your channel, so you should be good now.
So, look at that.
Gambling paid off.
Risking my entire channel for $10 paid off, guys.
Now I don't have to put the credit on the description anymore.
Like...
For the sake of not... Of not playing.
For the sake of me, so I could do less work.
I risked my entire channel, so I could do less work.
Let's go.
And it's, like, a five-second thing, too.
Like...
It was literally, like, five seconds of, like, oh, hey.
All I had to do was literally just, uh...
Um...
Wait, let's do full screen.
Wait, there's no full screen?
Oh.
That's interesting.
You know you would sooner be full... Okay, let's just play it on 60 frames, I guess.
Um...
But, yeah, I... I risked it all.
Worth the... Yeah, it was worth the 50-50.
So I could do five seconds of...
I could do, like, five seconds less work.
We take those.
Okay.
Alright, let's see.
I just gotta make sure.
Sorry, I'm, like, all over the place right now.
Uh...
This is fine.
This should be fine.
All in.
Yeah, I took that gamble and paid off.
Alright, is my sound guy alive?
Yeah, risking it all so I don't have to...
Control-C, Control-V.
I didn't execute you.
I just put blood on your hands.
That's different.
I showed them... I showed everyone...
That...
You're not one of them.
...
Clemo, thank you...
Welcome to Tomato Farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Alright.
Move around.
Oh, hey!
Pick up.
What's this?
Red Mercury Sprout.
Okay.
She's cute!
Can I change your clothes?
Haha!
Sorry!
She's cute!
Alright, now can I change your clothes yet?
Haha!
Okay.
You lose health when attacked and from some status effects.
Dropping from on height may also reduce your health.
Okay, so there is fall damage.
Stamina is spent when sprinting, dodging, and attacking.
Okay.
Raising the stat increases your maximum health, stamina, strength.
Oh, no.
I can't add chat for this, guys.
I just realized you don't even know what's good.
Oh, no!
How will I add chat now?
Raising the stat increase the damage of feathering control.
We don't know what's good!
No one knows!
It's okay!
The dragoons are 38 minutes into the future, might know.
Raising the stat increases the damage of magic controls.
Raising the stat...
Okay, so there's...
What the fuck is feathering?
Okay, so there is a weapon that does feathering.
When can I change my clothes?
Um, excuse me.
I have free DLC items.
Uh, where is it?
Okay, let me...
Okay, what do we not need?
We'll do vegetation quality.
We never need...
Like...
Grass.
Alright.
Okay.
LRB is like...
Okay, well, I like how the left side tells me...
Like...
Wait, if I'm here, does it...
How run?
Switch spells...
Okay, it doesn't tell you how to run yet.
Oh.
Flash...
Flash bomb.
Flash grenade.
Get flash banged.
Light!
I'm blind!
Oh my god!
Whoa!
Whoa.
Oh my god, is she okay?
Oh, cool.
Free sword.
Oh my god.
A hot lady gave me a free sword.
Nice!
Directed by...
Let's see who again.
Oh!
Looks pretty.
Oh, I love this.
It looks like a...
Chinese painting.
You know?
Like the...
What's it called in English?
The...
The ink...
Chinese paintings?
Oh my gosh, I don't remember what it's called in English.
It's been so long since I...
Said it in English.
Uh...
The scroll...
Is it a scroll painting?
Yeah.
Uh...
With the ink brushes and everything.
Ink painting...
Is it calligraphy?
Because there's like...
You can use it for calligraphy and stuff, but...
It's not...
Calligraphy.
I used to take...
Um...
Calligraphy classes.
And also like Chinese painting classes.
You think they're bad people?
Okay, yeah.
They might be.
You know, maybe they're not even bad people.
I just...
I just decided to stab them.
Like literally, they're not even doing anything bad.
That's cool.
I like the graphics.
The graphics are really nice.
Yeah, they're just...
They literally were just...
Gathering stuff for their family.
And I was like, I don't like you.
They're just...
I used to take like...
Um...
Uh...
Calligraphy and also like...
Ink painting cl...
Uh...
Classes.
Chinese painting classes too.
With the brushes and everything.
Reverent temple.
Oh, yeah.
This definitely feels very souls-like.
In terms of like...
And...
By what I mean, they like thrusted me into this world with like...
I don't...
Like I...
It's just exploring.
And stuff.
And then you uncover...
How to play the game.
As you go along.
You're awake at last.
Yeah, there's like no...
No...
No actual tutorial.
In a brooklet some days passed.
You lay passed out due to the feathering.
The feathering?
I moved you to the cave to recuperate.
She's becoming a bird!
I see...
No...
A man-eating fiend attacked worship's rise.
Six moons ago...
Oh, you're picking vegetables?
Time to die!
Thank you, thank you, this.
Reach out.
Thank you, thank you.
I
found this silk manuscript on your person.
Here.
Take it.
Should you have other concerns?
Pray.
Speak then.
Okay.
Uh...
Weapon Forged by the legendary...
So what do I have technically?
Where the fuck is my pay to win cosmetic?
Sorry, not pay.
Given to me for free cosmetic.
Can I actually stab him?
Alright, let's find out.
Okay, no.
You can't kill NPCs here.
Which is good.
Because like...
I might have done it.
That's good that I can't accidentally kill him.
What was that?
You're not from around here, are you?
The name's Charlene.
Charlene?
Don't you dare look down on me just cause I'm crippled.
My brother and I were once the town's finest heroes.
Oh, now you're blind.
What happened?
But now my brother's burden was finding medicine to treat me.
A pathetic fool.
I don't think no medicine can fix your blindness.
You don't...
I don't think you even have eyes anymore.
Oh my gosh.
Where are your eyes?
Could you do me a favor and deliver this to an oracle there?
She's hard to miss.
Oh.
That skips everything?
Okay.
Could you do me a favor?
I literally walked like one step away from him.
She's hard to miss.
She's had this old bracelet for as long as I can remember it.
She's a bit...
different.
You'll know her when you see me.
Oh, she doesn't look like a regular person, right?
She's still in town.
Please, check for me.
I've gone myself.
I can't.
Not in this pathetic state.
If you find her.
Don't tell her.
I'm stuck at the reverend temple.
Tell her.
You think he needs a somber story?
To make a name for herself.
Tell her.
I'll come back.
You're like, tell her I was a hero.
I made something.
Okay.
Wait, is that everything?
Yeah, tell her.
Okay.
I wanna be sure.
Okay, let's turn...
Uh...
Master volume and...
BGM volume here.
Okay, I hope that's better.
Alright.
So we got a special pill.
I know some of you guys were like, Oh, can you do Chinese voice?
The thing is...
Um...
I...
I don't really wanna read.
I-I don't really wanna read.
Reading is...
Sort of...
Very hard.
I'm tired right now.
I sort of just... Oh wait, donation box?
Who donated that?
Oh my gosh, Nance.
Nance, that was... Oh my gosh, he's tall.
He doesn't want it.
Understandable.
You seem to have recuperated well.
The old Taoist mentioned your encounter with that demon, Liu Hongnu.
I am glad to see you on your feet again.
But your arm...
The feathers are still there.
The feathering's a nasty curse.
Even the Taoist doesn't have a cure for it.
Oh no!
With your skills, maybe you should check out the Shusamptim.
Wait, what's so bad about the feathering, though?
But like, don't I get to have like, cool-ass powers?
Like, what's wrong with that?
I already see it like it's a bad thing.
Most people have to be carried out of the Reverend Temple.
You, though, you get to walk out on your own.
Yeah!
Xunyangzi may be harsh with his words, but he tends to my eyes every...
Yeah, get the... that's the flower!
Some of the worship's rise folk came here, fleeing.
But they didn't stay long.
They rushed back out, unaware of how dangerous the world truly is.
Okay, who are you?
Tao Qing?
Just a humble merchant seeking refuge.
I run a small trading business to make ends meet.
Do you happen to have any rare goods for me to take a look at?
Oh!
This face is all I've got left.
Mmm, smooth to the touch.
With a fragrance that's hard to come by.
This is no ordinary treasure.
Oh, but don't worry.
I won't be tempted to take it for myself.
What are you gonna do with my vase?
This place is no paradise for a merchant.
I'm thinking of heading to the Shu Sanctum.
I hear the Ming troops are stationed there, and it's a safer bet than this old temple.
I can trade with you, of course.
It would be an honor.
But for the real treasures?
I'm afraid I'll need to ask for a little favor in return.
Some thieves from Anilum stole my family's heirloom.
An ancient landscape painting.
Get it back for me, and I'll make it worth your while.
You can find Anilum by taking the side entrance from the stage at worship's rise, then crossing a long bridge.
Once you've retrieved the painting, meet me at the Shu Sanctum.
I'll have a reward waiting for you.
Okay.
Oh, DLC is... Oh wait.
Offer blood at Shrine to awaken his powers?
Oh, this is the... Here.
This is like the... The... Um... The bonfire.
But with blood.
With a blood god.
Oh, nice.
Offer blood at a shrine.
Is this where I level up?
Oh yeah, it is!
Having activated a shrine, you can enter the dream from there.
Entering the dream fully restores your health.
Uh... My blood fire.
And advances the story.
Uh... However, most enemies... Yeah, okay, so this is the... Uh...
Okay, so enter the dreams.
What is this?
Level up unlocks... Oh, there we go!
Must be in here, right?
Because it was not in here.
Ha ha ha ha!
Alright.
Let's... What's this?
Oh!
You may access the impetus repository from the shrines.
There you can spend the red mercury essence and lock nodes.
Thus, gaining new effect or discipline skill.
Press reset points for... to reset it.
Okay, so there's a skill tree, too.
There you can... Uh...
Okay.
Each weapon has... Uh...
Has ways in which to gain skyboard might.
You can acquire these by locking nodes.
You can also increase your maximum might.
With...
You think?
Okay.
So...
I could get the blink kick.
Oh!
That's interesting.
I also have, like, a skill tree...
On...
How big is it?
I don't know.
That seems a lot.
Ha ha ha!
There's, like, stuff all the way...
Like, at the top, guys.
There's, like, something on...
The fucking...
Centaur.
Ha ha ha!
Okay.
Evade all...
To avoid the enemy's attack fully.
Or...
Have...
Goddamn.
I can't add chat.
The game literally just came back.
So there's no meta.
That's so...
Ha ha ha!
I can't...
No one knows what the meta is!
Oh my god!
Ha ha!
Drop down.
Load to launch a fierce kit.
UC for greater.
Super for long swords.
What sword do I have?
Ha ha ha!
The meta is unknown!
I don't know!
Ha ha!
I have to...
I define the meta now.
Um...
Follow your heart!
Oh, I can't even...
Oh, I can't even level this up.
I just realized...
Oh wait, no!
It's cause, like, it's...
It's this...
The meta is no meta.
Wait, before I go to the shrine...
Someone said I can, like, go to the...
Weapon skills.
What's my weapon skills?
Oh!
That's my weapon skill.
Okay.
But actually...
Oh my god, maybe I didn't...
Maybe I didn't...
What?
Where's my clothes?
Okay, it's okay.
I don't...
We'll do it...
Uh...
Vanilla style.
No extra cosmetics.
No pay to win.
I can do it.
We don't need pay to win.
Uh, therns.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yo, red mercury essence.
I love drinking mercury.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Okay, so that's skill.
Whoops.
Oh.
Oh, the skill is like...
Oops.
Whoops.
Accidentally drank my potion.
Guess I...
Oh my gosh.
I need the tutorial thing to show up again.
I accidentally drank my flask.
Okay, do I get my flask again?
Okay, I got three.
Okay, I do.
That's good to know.
Okay, that's...
The attack.
There's like...
I saw that there was a parry.
But I need to look at the tutorial thing again.
Hello?
Are you infected too?
Says the feathering outbreak in Worship's Rise.
Many have fallen ill.
First, feathers start growing on your arms.
Then you lose your mind.
Oh!
Before long, you're turning to a monster that craves human flesh.
Guys, maybe the feathering is not a good thing.
Shang Yanzi brought me to the Reverend Temple.
Guys, maybe that's not good.
The medicine has kept me going.
But who knows how long it'll last.
Oh, that sounds bad.
Your symptoms are lighter than mine.
Best stay here and recover.
Okay.
There's utter chaos out there.
Especially in Worship's Rise.
I doubt there are many survivors...
There's a thing that has too much burn.
Still waiting for the Taoist to check on me.
Take care out there, young lady.
Okay, nice.
I got a special pill.
Okay, we have to...
Sound settings.
Up by three.
Down by three.
And then...
Master volume up?
Okay.
Let me know if that's good.
Oh wait, there's a tutorial here.
Okay.
Combat.
Heavy.
Light.
Offer blood.
Entering the dream.
Wait.
I felt like there was more.
I feel like...
I felt like there was more stuff on my left side.
Oh, there we go.
Switch weapons.
Swift draw?
What's swift draw?
I saw the old Taoist carry you in the other day.
Looks like you caught the plague too, huh?
Feathers.
Growing on your arm now.
Just like mine.
He's got a heart of gold.
That old Taoist.
But who knows if you'll ever come up with a miracle cure?
What if he was the one that started all of this?
Wait, have you guys been stuck here for ages?
That means, like... clearly there's enough time for me!
Yeah, I was thinking, like... Clearly I have, like, plenty of time.
He is patient zero.
I mean, he's still okay.
All he has is just a cough, right?
He has a little cough.
It'll be fine.
Also, like, my stamina bar is at my bottom left.
I would say I'm not really a fan of how tiny my stamina bar is on the screen.
Like, that would be my critique so far.
Because it is very tiny and I feel like I'm gonna forget...
To look at it.
Yeah.
It's like my above-average stamina bar.
At the moment, I feel like you can't run unless... I don't know.
Unless I'm fucking crazy.
But it doesn't feel like I can... I cannot run.
The best I can...
Oh wait, no!
Okay, you have...
Is this running?
Am I running, or...?
Yeah.
Okay, you have to hold it.
Okay, never mind.
Okay, it's like you dash and then hold.
Yeah.
Gigantic claw marks.
Okay, now I know.
Okay, you have, like, a first dash before you start running.
And your run...
I think because there's no enemies.
It doesn't...
It doesn't look like...
The sand that goes down for now.
It doesn't open from the side.
Okay, I guess we'll go this way.
Okay, kill me open with the Revenant key.
Okay, so I guess it's to the right then.
Okay, there's gigantic claw marks.
Oh!
I can see that random guy sitting there on the fire.
To be fair, he does blend in with the nature.
Oh, nice!
Steam Bunny Bun!
Oh, well.
Look who's back.
Feeling lost, are we?
We are both wanderers of fate.
No need for formalities.
Now...
About the power in your left arm.
If you master it, you'll be unstoppable.
You might even rewrite destiny as we know it.
Ooh!
How about I introduce you to someone worthy?
Oh my god, what's wrong with your mouth?
You know how it goes.
What's wrong with you?
Oh!
What happened to you?
Oh my god, he looks so fucked up!
By the belt pinwheel.
Pressing dodge to shimmer...
To shimmer and void an enemy move grants one skyboard increases and...
Potency of skills, discipline skills, and weapon skills.
Okay, so how do I do that?
Okay.
Alright.
Hit me.
Oh, it's just a regular map.
Wait, did I do it?
Wait, what?
Okay, I timed it wrong.
Oh, there we go!
Boom!
There we go.
Okay, I got it.
I hope so, unless our mom cheated.
Oh?
I forgot what these are called.
It's been so long since I've seen them.
Oh, pinwheels!
Yeah!
That guy has scoliosis.
Might need to see a doctor for that.
Oh!
It's okay.
Can I do it?
Oh, nice!
Oh, shit!
Not nice!
Okay, but the dodges were cool though.
As I look at those cool dodges.
Wow!
Wow, shit!
Okay, okay, got it.
Sorry, I need to stop.
I'm sorry.
I'm fucking around too much.
Look, I was trying...
I'm just trying...
I was trying to figure out the dodges.
No!
Okay, I have fallen.
Okay, I need to focus there.
I was like...
Oh, wait, does it...
Is it scripted?
Maybe it's scripted.
Maybe it's scripted, guys.
Okay, it was not scripted, guys.
Dropping to zero help results in this makes you drop red makery based on your current madness.
After which you arrive at the...
Head back to place your cream.
Oh, okay.
The...
Yeah, it's Souls rules.
It is Souls-like.
Okay.
You adjust the camera mode on lock-on settings and then choose between standoff and classic.
Before you switch between the two.
For a rich visual experience, focus on the action.
Or perform...
Stable view for precision and quick reactions.
What am I on?
Okay.
You know what?
We want to look nice.
That's fine.
Wait, there's new people here.
Wait, what?
Oh, it was scripted!
Oh!
Oh, shit!
I thought he was a good person!
I was like, hey there.
I was like, where is that guy?
I was like...
Where is he?
I thought he was like...
I don't know.
I...
I thought he wanted to talk to me, you know?
Like...
I didn't realize that they were bad people.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna burn.
Goodbye.
He just...
Like, he just went up and stabbed me!
I...
I don't understand!
Why did he stab me?
Like, I'm just...
Just a regular guy!
Okay.
I understand now, though.
I understand.
I can't believe he would just stab me like that!
Jesus!
What the fuck?
They cost so much damage!
Is he okay?
Okay.
Alright, where's my thing that I pick up?
Wait, how do I...
Oh, there it is.
It's blue.
Jesus Christ!
Okay.
They...
Do a lot of damage.
Okay.
There's no jump attacks, by the way.
Oh my...
Get me out of...
What?!
I can't believe I'm dying to Dorya!
Okay.
It's hard because, like...
I'm, like, trying to, like, unlearn Elden Ring controls into this.
So...
There's no...
I'm...
I'm, like, thinking my sword is the speed as my other weapon.
As, like, my katana.
Which I realize it's not...
Not true.
There we go.
See?
Okay, there we go.
We got this.
I figured it out.
Okay.
And then I got my...
Red Mercury back.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Didn't I...
Do some...
Oh!
Okay!
So...
After my dodge...
Like, I can do this.
And that uses the ability for it.
There we go.
Alright.
I figured it out.
After your dodge, I have to either use LB or LT.
Okay.
Go this way.
Nice.
You have two weapons equipped at any time.
Switch weapons.
Oh, okay.
This is where I can equip different weapons.
Uh...
Level two agility.
Mighty axe.
Plus one.
So this is more...
Okay.
Oh, I can block with this.
Okay, there's this.
Okay, this one lets me block.
So each...
Alright.
Nice.
Oh, yeah.
I can put two weapons now.
So I can swap.
After this and Elder Ring, you have to unlearn this control...
Wait, is he a good person?
Okay, he...
I...
Wait.
I gotta talk to him first before I do anything.
Who are you?
Oh, I have amnesia.
Oh, yeah.
I have amnesia.
Bayou?
They say it leads to memory loss.
Yeah.
Okay, but is it really that bad?
Like,
you know...
At least, like, I won't...
I will already be crazy, so I won't get, like, mad...
Like, mad me crazy.
The Shu Sanctum.
Okay.
Apparently, if you eat too much human meat, you can go crazy.
Because, like, there's, like, a...
Was it...
There's, like, a parasite that, like, fucks you with your brain.
If you encounter danger, don't fight.
I'll follow your trail and find you.
Oh, and...
Take this.
This bamboo lantern.
I found it nearby.
Hard to believe such craftsmanship still lingers here.
It's a reminder of how vibrant this town was.
The fireflies inside.
They seem to glow endlessly.
A useful light for your path.
I've tested it personally.
With this, you'll have both hands straight for weapons.
Oh, it's only if you eat the brain?
Oh, so there's no consequences.
To be in camp.
Since we got separated.
Many of the Imperial Guards have been sneaking around the Tang Emperor's palace.
Technically, there's no consequences, then.
The place has already been ransacked by rebels.
Technically, yeah.
Something's not right.
I will track down the boatmen.
And we'll meet at the pass.
What about the boatmen?
Only get caught.
Follow them, and you'll find me.
Okay.
We'll just have to follow them.
Um...
Where is the...
What's the lantern go?
And light the...
And use again to extinguish.
Okay.
So this is my lantern.
Uh...
Overtime for certain durations.
Oh, okay.
Alright.
We'll go this way.
Oh, 11 skills.
Light attack.
Cast spells.
Oh, that's why they don't like me.
That makes sense.
That's right.
Get your ass out of here.
How dare you call me a monster?
Because of that, I'll kill you to prove that I am.
I am one a monster.
That's right.
It's a circle.
Alright.
I like the halberd.
Spin to win.
Exactly.
Where do I go?
This way?
He did point to me on where I should be going.
But then like...
He just pointed at a general direction.
So like...
It wasn't that helpful.
Not gonna lie.
It took you here in my last $10.
Spend them on buying your birthday merch.
Um...
Thank you for the super chat kill.
Thank you.
I hope you...
I hope you enjoy my birthday merch.
When it comes.
That avoid any...
Grants one stack of skyboard.
You can learn unique weapon mechanics in the...
To gain even more.
Impedus repository.
Oh, is that the skill, right?
That's the...
Allows you to counter enemy attacks.
How does no effects against such as...
Okay.
Back in...
Back in everything.
Okay.
Spin!
Alright.
You can equip three jade pennants.
Uh...
Choosing the pennant.
That best fit your weapon style will give you advantage in combat.
Okay.
Nice.
Wait.
He didn't even have any.
What the fuck?
Why did that come up?
I didn't even get a pennant.
Like...
Haha.
Oh.
Oh wait.
I did.
Wait.
What?
When did that show up in my inventory?
I didn't even...
What?
I didn't even see that.
Okay.
I was like, huh?
When the fuck did I pick it up?
Alright.
Oh.
There's items.
Yay.
Free stuff.
At least like, the item...
When...
The items are like, super noticeable so I can't miss them.
A flying dagger.
Good or bad?
Hello?
Oh.
Good.
Feathers on your left arm.
Yeah.
That's a sign of feathering.
Mmhmm.
Most would've lost their minds by now.
But...
You remain in control.
Hmm.
Fascinating.
The power of feathering was the one of yours.
I can't do it.
How you manage to contain it, I don't know.
But make no mistake, your left arm is the key to unleashing its full strength.
Yes, that power is itching to course through you.
But... I'm afraid you're not ready to command it.
Not yet.
Oh, I don't know the magic yet.
Take this.
Oh, Mercury!
You've got what it takes to wield that power.
What do I have to do?
Okay, so you can't accidentally kill the NPCs.
That's... that's good to know.
I swear that I can't jump, though.
Yummy, yummy, Mercury!
This pretty lady singledookie, I'm asking for myself.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, how do I get...
Okay, I have to be on the other side.
Evil?
Evil.
Spin!
That's right.
That's right!
Get out of here!
Alright.
Spin!
I like the spin!
I feel like maybe this is only good for like...
Regular...
Enemies.
And consume sky might to unleash a powerful...
Swift draw.
Oh!
Do I have it?
Okay, no I don't.
Wait.
Lie to me!
Okay.
Oh, shit!
Wait, wait, wait, wait a minute.
Wait, before any of that happens...
It's beam time.
Spin!
Oh, shit!
That's right!
Get out of here!
Okay, why the fuck do I do any other...
Use any other weapon.
This sword fucking sucks.
Hello?
Are you alive?
Whoops!
Hello?
Okay, I think he's dead.
Alright.
Oh, yeah.
No, they...
They're definitely dead.
Oh, my God!
They're...
Are these monks?
They're so messed up!
What do the monks think?
They don't...
They don't even do anything!
They're like peaceful!
They're vegetarians!
What do the monks even do to you?
Bro, they're just harmless vegetarians.
That's messed up.
Alright.
Let's see...
Did I tell you...
Oh, I know.
I did tell you guys, sir.
For those who don't know...
One time, during a school trip...
My teacher took us to a temple.
And...
At that time, I was really young.
So I didn't realize that all the monks there working...
Or like...
You know, we're like at the temple...
Not working, sorry.
What's the word?
Not working!
Um...
That live there...
Were vegetarians!
Uh...
And so...
My mom...
Packed me...
Um...
A chicken burger...
For lunch!
So...
We went to like...
We...
A...
Uh...
Went to like...
A restaurant that they own...
And like, cook at...
Um...
And like, you know...
Everything was like...
Made out of tofu...
Or was like...
Vegetables...
Toe vegetables...
And like...
I was really young...
Ignorant...
So...
I was like...
I'm hungry.
Cause they're like...
Look, this is...
Um...
This is chicken, like...
This is...
Tofu...
But it's shaped like a chicken.
Like...
You know...
They made like...
Tofu...
Chicken...
And stuff like that.
And...
I ate it, and I was like, Oh, this is not for me...
And I'm really hungry.
So...
And I just brought up my chicken burger and just ate it... at the restaurant!
And then, my teacher... like, I was just like, yum, yum, yum, yum.
And then, my teacher, like, went up to me and was like, put that away.
And I was like, what?
I was so kind.
Because I didn't know.
I was so ignorant.
I didn't know.
I was the only one that... I was the only kid that did that.
Because, like...
I think I was the only one where, like, my parent... like, my mom packed me food, just in case.
But hungry!
If a character's grayscale portrait appears, it means you have yet to complete their quest.
The portrait with the spirit wants their quest to complete.
Map and fully restore your health.
Okay.
Okay, this...
Okay, so there's block.
I can have ultra block.
And then...
Increases the stack to two.
What is this?
Okay, I feel like I'm not gonna use...
Okay, I'm gonna use this.
The thunderous cleave.
Yeah.
There we go.
The four of attack...
It grabs three stacks if it hits an enemy.
Use to cast spells.
Okay, we're gonna use the axe.
Oh my god!
That...
I am so intimidated now.
I...
What am I looking at?
What?
That opened a...
Like...
That...
It just went from level one to like...
Level...
50.
Like...
Oh my god!
I got the...
What?
Oh my god!
Okay.
I...
I don't have enough anyway.
I'll let future Doki handle that.
Uh...
Okay.
I'll let...
Future Doki can deal with that.
I...
I don't know what I was looking at.
The skill tree just got skill treeed.
What was the...
We're in location.
Buddha Caves.
Cliffs.
I mean, that's where I...
Oh, wait.
There...
These are the quests that I have to do.
At that area?
Did I not do the quests already?
Okay.
I guess I have to...
Go...
Back?
Okay.
Apparently there's some quests I haven't done yet.
How do I...
I guess like every level I do?
Yeah.
Alright.
It's Groundhog Day.
Maybe this way?
Okay.
This guy seems like really tough though.
Like he seems like...
He really did not...
Does not want me there.
So maybe I shouldn't go that way.
Okay.
But...
I didn't go left though.
I went right instead of left.
So maybe...
Okay.
Speed!
Oh shit!
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I'm a little EP.
Okay.
Guess not.
Oh my god.
He just stabs me like that.
Okay.
There we go.
Alright.
Beyblade time.
I had to do a little spin-y spin.
Okay.
So I didn't go left.
Maybe that's where I get my quest.
I like that on my top right there's a little guy just running.
I don't know what that means.
But I like his style.
Okay.
So it was...
Oh, it's just a dead end.
Is there really just a dead end?
I have to like remember that...
Is there parrying?
Well, there is a block.
But they said like...
They were saying like...
Oh, it doesn't give that much of an advantage.
Like...
It doesn't do much.
But...
Maybe I...
Maybe I'm just not doing it right.
Alright.
Okay.
Apparently...
I also don't like water.
Also some...
Only some weapons have parry.
Because like...
The sword doesn't...
Alright.
Apparently...
When you have the feathering...
Water bad.
Water.
It's scary.
Because I'm the wrong type of bird.
Apparently.
Which is...
Understandable.
What the fuck?
That should've hit.
Alright.
Well, that's good to know.
That's good to know.
Water bad.
Let's grab this guy out first.
Okay.
Get out of here.
Oh, wait.
He's dead.
Okay, nice.
He did get out of here.
Uh...
I slipped and then...
I died.
That's...
You know what?
That's good to know.
That's...
I needed to know...
Know the dangers of water.
Hehehehe.
Cause they're like...
I have two quests here.
That I have yet to do.
So I'm like...
Wondering.
Where do I go?
Okay.
I guess...
I didn't have to go there then?
I guess I'll go back.
Cause...
I went everywhere this way.
So I'm just gonna go back then.
Maybe fight the Armored Man.
But the Armored Man's scary.
Alright.
Hahahaha.
But he looks so scary, guys.
Alright.
We'll fight the Armored Man.
Wait, what?
There's a child here.
Where's the child?
Wait, we all heard the child.
Oh, it's the sound guy.
Did you...
Is everything...
Okay?
Oh, there he is!
Wait, how do I get to this child?
Wait, I can't jump!
There's a child!
Literally right there!
Yeah, I can't get there at all.
Oh my god.
It's so weird not being able to jump though.
He's right there!
He's literally right there!
Look!
See?
It's a child!
But I can't get there.
Right?
I can't...
Apparently, I don't...
I don't have the fucking leg strength to do any jumps right now.
Alright, we'll fight the Armor guy.
We'll see how this goes.
Guys, he has a lot of HP.
Guys.
I don't think that's gonna go well for me.
Hehehehe.
Oh my god, okay.
Okay, it is doable.
It is doable.
But he...
Yeah, he does have a lot of HP.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
I understand.
Nice.
Alright.
It's not as bad.
And then I realized I still can't open it.
And then...
What's the point?
What's the point of guarding a door that's locked?
Like, what is your purpose?
I can't even go through.
I...
What?
Right...
Right on.
I got him.
Alright.
Then I leave.
I can't even...
In case you open it.
He's a two-factor authentication.
I...
Goddamn two-factor authentication.
Am I right?
Okay.
Now I gotta figure this out.
Alright.
Okay.
Fuck.
Um...
Charges...
Plus...
Okay.
I do not have enough.
I don't have enough.
Okay.
I don't have to figure this out.
I...
I don't have to figure this out yet.
Thank God.
It's fine.
I don't have to figure this out yet.
One new item?
One new item.
One thing I got.
Any item?
Blast.
Enter your dream.
Restorer's HP.
There's so many.
Okay.
Oh, so these are the... these are like the little runes that I can do.
Alright.
Um...
Where do I go up here?
No one...
Hello?
What other pathway could I take?
A ladder?
No, that's...
Oh, is it the ladder?
It's the ladder.
It's a different area.
I'm pretty sure.
Alright.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Yeah, it's a different area.
Okay, that's good.
I thought it would be like a shortcut.
It's usually, you know, when you kick down the ladder, it's the shortcut.
There's a lot of dead people here.
Oh, I have a spell!
Oh!
Cool!
Equip spells?
A spell known putting out to subdue ordinary demons.
It's simple as even cast it.
Unleaves a blade that deals magic damage.
Okay, so why is the spell?
Where's my spell meter?
Oh shit!
Why?
What does my spell meter do?
Oh shit, sorry.
I was like looking at my... trying to find the spell meter.
Okay.
Is English my second language?
What the fuck?!
Oh my god!
Okay.
How?
Get the fuck off me!
Okay, you know I'm glad I killed your defense lift goblins later, last time.
Okay.
Okay, I was trying to figure out...
Wait.
What?
Oh!
I have to find it!
Okay.
I'm glad.
I'm glad I killed your family earlier.
They were defenseless.
Alright.
So the spell is like, one use?
And...
Like, this is what restores it.
So when they're flying away...
I think?
I'm like learning about this as I go along.
Lock on to light attack while performing a plantless triggers and obliterate strike when successful against small to medium.
Okay.
I have to...
Oh, that's cool.
That's a cool move.
Can I make it?
Guys, I...
Okay, there...
Don't, don't, don't...
Guys, I don't think I made it.
I don't think I made it.
I got...
Instructions unclear, apparently.
No, I can't even get the item!
Okay.
Okay, so there is back stab.
That's good to know.
Also, he was very injured and I might have just...
Oh, I...
Oh, I might have just...
Oh, wait.
I think this guy was a doctor.
And he was trying to help these people.
Oh, I might have...
I might have committed a crime.
I...
You know what?
It's too...
I'm too far gone now.
I...
Might as well fully commit.
I might have made a terrible mistake.
Why did you kill those innocent monks?
Uh...
No witnesses.
You're right.
No witnesses, guys.
Uh...
Okay, so...
Well, let's do position in front.
And...
Or behind them and execute a light attack.
Okay.
Okay, so if they're doing that, I have to use a light attack on them.
Okay, that's good to know.
Alright, I believe...
I believe that's our boss.
Okay, she'll...
Clearly she'll drop down.
Wait, actually, let me heal real fast.
What the fuck?
Nice.
Okay, is that...
I assume...
Oh yeah, that is.
Okay.
Alright, that's good to know.
Watch this.
Oh, I couldn't do...
Wait.
I can abuse that.
Wait, I can actually abuse that.
But...
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Okay, guys.
Wait, this is actually perfect.
I...
Technically, that's a high ground.
Oh shit.
This is why you can't jump.
This is...
Not the cheese.
Yeah, dude.
I was just elevated.
Just a little bit.
And it counted.
Comes in three types.
Oaths, wisdom, and memory.
You can socket...
Benedictions onto weapons or remove them at shrines.
Benediction greatly increases your...
Okay, so they also have little rocks that I can put...
Might reduce damage taken for time.
Okay.
That's cool.
Pure skill.
That's why I can't jump, guys.
Alright.
I found the cheese.
I just gotta be like...
A little bit higher than them.
And just drop down.
Oh nice, this is chest.
What did I get?
Forgotten remembrance?
What is that?
What even...
What even is that for?
What?
Didn't say anything.
A remembrance...
Actually...
A remembrance that was forgotten.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Do I have to backtrack?
Where do I go after that?
Oh.
Is there like a pathway over here?
Oh, there was.
Oh.
There is.
Okay, nice.
There was a pathway over here.
And there's an item too.
Okay.
That's good to know.
Whoa!
Hahaha.
That's right.
You missed the wrong...
The wrong woman.
That's right.
Get out of here.
Alright.
We'll get rid of this guy too.
Chop?
Alright.
A faint red feather.
What's this?
This is also a feather?
Lost package.
Oh.
There might be quest items?
Maybe?
I could drop down from here.
He's just sleeping.
But there might be other people I could have to kill here.
Okay.
Alright.
How do I go back?
Okay.
You know what?
Yeah.
I'll kill the sleeping guy.
Fuck it.
I'm already in too deep.
Okay.
Oh shit.
I made a noise.
Whoops.
It's alright.
It still works.
I'm already in too deep.
Alright.
Flying dagger.
Oh nice.
What's this?
Airplane.
Oh.
Delicate armor.
Okay.
I...
I was gonna say...
Oh.
It gives me...
This is like a magic build.
Yeah.
That's a...
No.
I was like...
Hmm.
A delicate leggings.
A delicate...
Would this armor be better?
Ha ha ha ha ha.
I wonder...
I wonder if this armor would make me stronger.
Oh shit.
Okay guys.
I will show you after I kill these men.
Boom.
What the fuck was...
What was that?
Huh?
Okay.
I wanna get the...
He like does dashes and stuff.
So it fucks with me.
Come on.
Trick me.
Oh my god.
The speed for it is like...
It like fucks with me a little.
There you go.
Oh wait.
That hits me?
Okay.
Alright.
What is this?
Oh.
Leg wraps.
Okay.
Is this better though?
I have less feathery magic.
But it's that...
Okay.
I'll show you guys what it looks like.
Ooh.
I'm...
Lucky respect.
Okay.
I'll give you...
Wait.
Red tassel spear.
Um.
Maybe I like the spear more.
Is the spear better?
Okay.
Do it again.
I'll just put this thing on.
I was not expecting it.
Oh my gosh.
Why do I have red eyes?
What the fuck is wrong with me?
What the fuck?
He has a gun?
Why does he have a fucking gun?
Jingle jingle.
Okay, how do I time a gunshot?
Okay, that was bullshit.
Like, how the fuck do I time that?
That's cheating.
I was not expecting a gun.
Randomly in my Souls game.
There was no pattern!
What the fuck?
Let me steal this real fast.
Okay, that was cheeky.
I just think I have ears.
What the fuck?
What?
Okay, that's not fair.
Oh my god, that is not fair.
Okay, I didn't realize that it can... I didn't realize it does that.
Okay.
All right.
Well, now I know.
Okay.
Okay, now I know.
Now I know when he does that jump, like, I gotta go.
I gotta leave.
Okay.
Okay, this is really bad because I haven't found any... I think, like, the checkpoints at the moment do not seem very obvious.
Oh my god, that's a gun.
That's a gun.
I can't fight that.
I have no HP.
I actually have no HP.
The matchlock musket were well established by the side.
Belarious, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, but why do the demons have guns, though?
Like, that's my issue.
Why do the demons have guns?
I guess I'll use this for now.
Because I... I need HP.
Gun is gun.
And the demons gotta defend themselves, though, Kee.
Like... Like... There's no way of time for this!
Oh my god!
Because they're demons!
Okay...
Well, now I know that if they shoot that, it explodes.
That's, like, the dynamite in this world.
There's a lot of things, places to go.
I'm, like, trying to make sure that I don't miss much.
I am worried that I don't know where the checkpoint is.
I'm gonna go left side, because the other guy was there.
I have no... I don't know which one I like.
I like the halberd and the spear.
I don't like... I definitely don't like the sword, though.
I'm not a fan of the sword.
The damage... I know it's, like, faster, but the damage is way too low for my liking.
I'll go here first.
Okay, so...
Special items in pick-up during your journey can be equipped on your item bar.
To do this, navigate to equipment and...
On specific... when used with certain objects may trigger a chain reaction that eases combat battles.
Okay, so I might have a...
bomb?
Okay.
So, I can equip... this.
And then... oh...
Okay, and then...
Uh...
Where's my... how do I swap?
Oh, here.
And then...
I did it.
Oh, cool!
Okay.
That's how you do it.
Alright, I did it.
I mean, it killed like...
Okay, it killed more than one guy.
Whoops.
Look, sir.
I don't wanna be a bad person.
Ha ha ha.
Oh, shit.
I don't know.
I just didn't dodge...
For it.
I know!
Okay.
I...
He was a bad person.
Okay...
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Okay, we gotta go all the way... Oh my god, there's so... I must have missed a checkpoint somewhere.
Cause there's no way, there's no checkpoint at all.
He literally blew up three of his... Okay, three of his friends were fucking demons!
Like, at that point, maybe I'm not the bad person.
I did not expect him to be, like, that strong, not gonna lie.
But...
So, like, magic is, like, super rare.
Cause it's coming from these flowers.
Oh, I keep my weapon, though.
Okay.
Parry this.
You can't parry with a spear, so...
You can parry with... this.
Um, it is, like, with...
It's with the L... LT?
Yeah.
You can parry with this, but...
Not with a spear.
My god, that hit you!
Oh my god, I hate these...
I hate these guys so much.
I actually hate them.
I hate them so much.
I...
Can I get magic back?
Oh, I can get magic back for dodging?
Okay.
I hate the... the jockeys.
Okay, I can do this again.
That's good that I died.
Okay, that's off, right?
That's off, right?
Okay, we gotta kill...
Why do they do so much damage?
Bro, like, all you do is pray!
Okay.
Okay, these guys...
I have to...
I'm sorry.
I...
No witnesses.
Alright, next.
Bye.
Alright.
I don't know if I have invincibility frames.
He prayed for TPS.
Alright, I'm just gonna...
Skip this area.
It was like...
Here, and then we go this way.
Oh my god, it's Gunman.
Okay, we're Soling now.
Where I skipped this area.
This is...
There's too much stuff here.
Okay, where's that fucker that was hiding?
Okay.
Where is he?
Wait, what?
Okay, there you are.
Now, where's your friend?
That's fucking right!
I knew you were alive!
Get out of here!
I hit first, idiot!
That's right!
Okay.
Halbert is actually...
It's so much better.
It is actually so much better.
Okay, now we do this again.
Wait, what?
What the?!
Oh my god, I can't even read it.
I...
I can't even read it.
I'm so confused.
What was that?
What...
Like, I...
I couldn't even process what that was.
Okay, here we go.
Killing non-feathered humanoids or dying in combat will increase your madness.
However, deviating most feathered enemies and killed targets will reduce your madness.
You will only lose...
Excuse me?
Like, am I...
Am I writing a thesis right now?
You will only lose...
Um...
Some...
Red...
Mercury...
If you perish...
Perish while less than 50% madness.
You will lose...
Plenty of red mercury if you perish while at above 50% but below.
How crazy am I?!
You will lose...
Okay.
There's a morality system?!
What philosophy class am I in?!
Turn red while at above...
Oh my god, that's...
That's why my eyes were red.
But they were trying to kill me!
Like, I...
Those humans were trying to kill me!
Like...
Huchir has turned red.
Activating related nodes in the MPs repository grants enhanced effects.
The modding marks begin appearing while at above.
This makes you deal and take increase...
Oh my god!
That makes...
So much more sense now!
And I...
I was like, what the fuck?
Why are these bugs doing so much damage?
Pray by offering divine gifts?
I have to give him gifts too?!
I...
Oh my god!
I think I have to give my divine god...
The...
A super chat?
Shall you perish while at full madness?
A powerful demon that chases you will madness it...
My inner demon will...
Okay...
So I...
I...
Basically...
I lost...
Okay...
So I lost all the red mercury from that.
That actually makes so much more sense.
I was like, wondering why...
This monk did so much damage to me.
And I was like, bro, what the fuck?
I literally saw you praying.
Like...
Like how...
Like, look at him!
Like...
Look at this guy!
That...
You're...
Crazy dick!
You think we tried Goon's area?
Okay, this is definitely a lot more complicated...
Than I thought it was gonna...
Than I thought...
Oh, I have another sword!
It's...
A lot...
Down, so...
Okay, we'll try this sword then.
It's definitely a lot more complicated than I thought.
Which isn't a bad thing.
But it definitely is like, you know...
Jesus...
No!
I just...
God!
Oh my god!
I hate these jumping guys!
I was gonna say...
It was...
It's a lot more complicated.
Which sets it apart from other souls.
Like...
It has it's own thing.
Or a guy in the souls.
Like...
Um...
Genre.
For now, I'm like...
I'm like wondering where...
Where is the checkpoint though?
At least I can keep the knife.
I don't really understand the...
Madness system that much.
To be fair.
Okay.
The madness system is...
It's a little confusing for me.
You kill non...
Yeah!
But they...
They did it first!
It's not even my fault!
They started it!
Okay, I can finally do this.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, these guys are feathered though.
So like...
It's good that I killed them.
I get less mad.
Yeah.
No!
Like...
If they're feathered...
I get less madness though.
That's what they said.
So I had to kill them.
They had madness guys!
I'm...
I'm helping the world!
Yeah.
Feathered enemies equals less madness.
So like...
Even though they were defenseless...
Like...
I was doing the right thing.
Okay.
I feel like this is better though.
Against this guy.
Time first!
That's right!
And then...
Like the weapon swaps are like...
Nice though.
I'm feathered...
Yeah, and I hate my own kind.
Like...
Oh shit.
Okay, that didn't work.
Yeah, the swap is like smooth though.
I like that.
Oh my god!
Oh my...
Whoa!
They're so fast!
Okay.
Okay, that was awkward.
I live.
I-I don't know how I did that.
Okay.
Now, now, now I'm definitely having madness now, though.
I will admit, this might lead, might lead to madness.
I realize, like, I don't lose a lot, too, of, uh...
Okay, they, they started it!
We all saw that they started it, guys.
What do you mean, have mercy?
Okay, see?
Look, my eyes aren't red yet.
It's fine.
They literally started!
I'm still gonna try and grab that item.
I love it.
I'll grab this item, too, yoink.
I feel like I don't lose that much runes, do I?
Yeah, I don't.
I actually don't lose that much.
Okay.
All right.
What the fuck?!
What?!
Okay, I hate these guys.
Those little jumping things they do.
There's a gauge at the corner for how mad...
I can't...
Where?
Which corridor?
I can't tell right now.
Oh my god, thank god.
The shrine was there this entire time.
Okay, let me...
Let me...
Give me a sec.
Let me perform my blood offering before I help you.
Okay.
What do you want?
Oh, now you don't want to talk?!
Okay.
Wait.
Can I kill this?
What?
Oh my god, you're so lucky I can't jump.
You're so lucky I can't jump.
Oh shit, hello.
You have a name, so you must be important.
Wait, that's it?
You fallen and couldn't get up?
I just stepped out for a breather and ran into a fine woman.
Wait, was this a trap?
Who are you?
Name's Wu-Gang.
I'm Du-Tanga's right hand.
I take care of the big jobs.
Those temple fools keep sniffing around for my treasure.
Soon as I send word to the boss...
Wait, I'm like Gollum?
That's it?
There's temple fools too.
Okay, he doesn't seem like that bad of a guy.
All right, time to...
While I was trying to get invoked to pray.
Pray will grant you rare items at a cost of increased items.
Okay, how about before I pray, let me upgrade the stuff I can.
Well...
Wait, I don't?
Oh, lost remains.
Oh, there you go.
Forgotten Remembrance.
Okay, so now I have three.
Okay, oh, that's what Forgotten Remembrance is.
So each of them...
Okay, I get it now.
Oh, that is...
Oh, that is complicated.
Okay, I feel that...
Wait, did I not do this?
Did I not save?
Flickering Blade.
I currently...
Oh my god.
What the...
It's moving so fast, I can't even see what it does.
Okay, I can launch a counter.
Heavy dash and the final strike stacks you have activated.
Use sacks can be inverted to set a ratio by landing spear light attacks.
Okay, I'm just...
Ungabunga.
Sorry.
I saw...
Ungabunga.
That I...
I'll just...
Ungabunga.
It seems a lot easier for me.
I feel like that's the way.
What is Ungabunga?
I use axe.
That is Ungabunga.
All right.
Time to be...
Oh.
Can I...
Benedict this still?
Oh no.
Okay.
It's time to be mad, I guess.
Oh wait.
I don't need to.
I don't need any of these though, right?
Raise one spirit and most likely tamed, given the...
And ward off evil.
Boost all status.
Respect resistance for certain...
Generally boost recovery.
And here it does increase your madness.
Grind five stacks of skyborne might.
Okay.
So this should be fine.
Let's...
What's my thing?
Okay.
We got enter a dream.
All right.
Ungabunga.
Things should be okay now.
I don't know what to do with this bird though.
He's just chilling there.
Wait.
Why am I...
Why am I the bad person?
They literally murdered this village.
But oh, I have to fight my inner demons?
Like...
They literally killed children!
But oh no, that's...
Me killing because they're human.
I'm the bad person.
This guy literally was dragging behind.
He killed children!
Okay.
Because I'm feathered.
That's too far.
There's no tree, pheasant, quill.
I refuse to hunt his tail.
Poke, poke, poke, poke, poke.
Okay, he's fast.
What the fuck?
He's so fast.
It's okay.
Oh my...
What?
He's not...
He's not even doing anything and I get hit.
Okay, I understand now.
Yeah, the hitbox is crazy there.
Alright.
Let's grab this item.
Oh, hit the bird.
I get a feather?
I can't hit him.
He's so light.
Oh, unless maybe...
Oh my...
How the fuck do I reach you?
Like...
Oh, there we go.
I reached him.
Okay, I hit him from there.
Oh, that's a lot of blood.
Alright.
Hello.
That's right.
You can't escape from me.
I'm mad.
Alright.
Okay, I need a key.
Yeah, I need...
How do I hit that guy?
Okay, it has to be magic.
There has...
There's no way.
Alright, health pill.
I got the feather.
Yeah, I got the feather.
Okay, just talking about the temple.
Oh?
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
What?
Are you okay, ma'am?
Oh my god.
Ma'am, please.
Please, ma'am.
Okay, so...
He does...
She does poison damage.
She is not okay.
Maybe I'll...
I won't try the fast.
Oh shit.
Okay, clearly she just...
She just fits.
Oh wait, maybe I could...
Oh wait.
Oh my god.
I do not like...
Okay, never mind.
Never mind.
Back to Ungabunga.
I was like...
What am I doing?
I'm just dancing around.
Alright.
Alright, I should never go...
Away from Ungabunga.
I'm literally just dancing around here.
I...
I don't know.
Am I evil yet?
No.
I'm not.
This way.
Okay, my inner demons.
It's still okay.
Okay, this has to be a feather.
Like, he's literally eating the corpse.
And like...
That's a bad thing now.
Oh my god.
Bro, your fucking head.
I'm not doing a bad thing, guys.
We're supposed to kill them.
Alright.
We got Mercury.
Shoot.
Mercury.
Sprout.
Oh, chest.
He just wants a hug.
Okay, I swear.
I fucking knew it.
I heard him.
Okay.
Ungabunga.
Did I get lost remains?
Oh, this is for upgrades.
Uh...
Is there anything else here?
Oh shit!
There's so many!
Oh my god.
So I'm putting them out of their misery, guys.
I'm doing a good thing.
Swing!
Holy shit!
They do too much damage.
Give them a hug!
Alright.
I'm putting them out of their misery, guys.
I can't believe Doki would kill the sick and injured like that.
Look.
But they were evil, sick and injured.
So I balance it out.
They were evil.
Attack or charging on heavy attacks and striking small and medium-sized from behind can cause them to lose their balance.
Leaving them vulnerable when this position in front...
Oh wait, no.
That's literally the same thing I did.
What's this?
No food remains.
It's time to lock the gate and keep the last of the meat.
Her tears never cease.
Is she afraid the people I worship will rise?
Will comfort her?
Fear not.
I keep the key closed.
Only over my dead body will anyone set foot in the temple.
Okay, so this...
Where the fuck...
Where's his dead body?
Alright.
So that has to be a boss fight.
So I'm gonna...
I'm gonna level up real fast.
I realized, like...
Um...
For character stats...
You level up with a skill tree.
So I find that interesting for a Souls game.
Okay.
I find that interesting.
Okay, uh...
You gain one stack...
What this...
What is this?
But I don't have burn.
That's the thing.
Locking costs the stamina.
Okay, I feel like...
Yeah, we need that.
Um...
And I have one more.
Cannot be upgraded.
Why not?
Oh, because I don't...
Wait, what?
Oh.
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, I can put more into this.
That makes sense.
Okay.
Sorry, I'm, like, processing my skill tree.
Um...
But yeah, you can definitely do a lot of different builds.
Right now.
I'm just doing this build.
Oh, wait.
I forgot.
To reset.
So I can have my full...
Man...
Uh...
Heal potions.
Healing is hard in this game.
Because, like...
In more so a way where...
Um...
It's not...
It's, like...
A lot slower.
It's a lot slower than Elder Ring.
Which I've noticed.
Let's kill this guy first.
Okay.
Yeah, it's way slower.
Like, I actually have to, like, find cover when it comes to healing.
Which I'm not used to.
Any items?
Any drops?
No.
Alright.
Okay, so I guess this has to be a boss fight.
Right?
Oh, yeah.
No, that...
That guy looks very boss-like.
This game is more like Dark Souls 1.
Oh, I see.
Oh.
Oh, does he have Feathered?
He has his inner demons.
Oh, is he Feathered too?
Or he's just a demon?
Okay.
What?
I...
I don't know his pattern at all.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I don't know any of his attacks.
Man.
Okay.
What?
Yeah, his weapon is sick.
I don't know.
His attacks are, like, really hard to telegraph.
Other than that.
I mean, that one was easy.
That one was easy.
But other than that.
Okay.
Jesus, what?
That hits me?
Okay.
Yeah, we're not winning this fight.
Stay still.
You don't deserve...
What?
That hits me too?
Okay.
It's interesting what hits me, though.
It's interesting.
Because I was like, That hits me?
Okay.
Okay, like when he plants it on the ground, there's a hitbox there.
That's like hard.
Okay.
The attack patterns are like really weird a bit.
Yeah.
Consume for greatest increase.
Consumes.
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright.
So, yeah.
It's AoE.
Okay.
So, his attack patterns are weird.
Like, it's hard to see what is the hitbox for it.
But I sort of get it.
But also like, I had to like think a little.
And also like, I realized because of the madness.
The madness.
The madness part makes it so I don't lose all my...
Uh... Mercury.
So, I have to be aware of that.
Yeah.
Alright.
Let's try this again.
Yeah.
So, you don't... You don't lose everything.
During your... During your fight.
Okay.
I feel like I can just, you know, say like...
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
Okay, nice.
That's right.
Mighty Dio.
Okay.
Yeah.
Like when he puts it... When he puts his...
Fucking thing down.
I still get hit.
Like, I don't expect that.
That fucks with me.
Okay.
Nice backstab.
Yeah.
That shit I don't like.
Okay.
Bum bub.
Bum bub bub bub bub bub bub.
Okay.
Nice.
Bum.
You fucker.
Alright.
Good damage though.
Oh my god.
I'm like so scared that...
Are you serious?
Okay.
Nice.
He has fire now?
God, he burned everything.
What is he doing?
Fireworks?
Now he has fireworks?
Oh, this is so punishing.
I will say it's definitely very punishing.
Because I don't have a lot of healers too.
Okay.
Wait, what?
What's the switch draw?
This?
What?
What am I doing?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Get out.
Get out of here.
Okay.
Okay, I have to get out though.
I don't have any more potions.
I don't know what he's doing.
He's...
He's like...
He has...
I don't...
Don't...
Oh wait.
He's so far away.
Like...
Okay, that has to be like too far to hit me.
Like, I'm worried when he does that.
When he puts it...
When he puts it down, you know?
Okay.
Okay, he's dead.
Holy shit.
So he was feathered.
Oh nice.
Look at that.
I did it.
I got less crazy.
Nice.
I got copper jug.
What the fuck did I get?
Wait, there's more?
It doesn't stop.
That's right.
I was like, there's more stuff?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Look, my brain is like expanding right now.
Like...
Alondra, welcome to Tomato Fire.
Welcome, welcome.
But wait.
There's more.
It keeps going.
Like...
I'm like, there's a new thing I gotta process.
Guys, give me a sec.
Clip onto your item hop bar and use it to endow your weapons with special effect.
Insert different bow needles and stone needles from within, thereby changing what type of...
Using specific bow needles before activating your temperance unlocks your weapon's hidden potential.
For March Graver...
Okay.
Um...
What is my weapon's hidden potential?
Uh...
Enable it to cause burn.
Okay.
Okay, cool.
So now...
True power in feathering isn't about a necessity.
Now I have burn.
It's about understanding it.
Okay.
I can now burn stuff.
How do I activate it though?
They really tell me how to activate the burn part though.
Discipline.
Use...
Wait, what?
How do I learn...
How do I do it?
Okay, here.
Poise break.
For extra...
Some moves have...
Move at deflect traits.
Okay, so here.
So like, this is how you deflect.
Charge, heavy attack, fleetness.
Uh...
Okay.
There's like one thing...
Where...
Where is the...
The acupuncture...
Shit.
Like...
Is it...
I don't remember what it's called.
They were so...
Oh my god.
Okay.
My brain is...
It's like going one ear out of the other right.
Oh, it's temper.
There we go.
In the tempering menu.
Okay.
How do I...
Okay, so...
I have to unlock it.
Okay, so I have to unlock it on my...
Oh my god.
Look at that fucking thing zoom.
Like...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Look at it.
Zoom so fast.
Oh, there's leech magic.
Okay.
I mean...
That's like the...
Vampire.
I like leech magic.
Leech seems good, right?
Okay.
Yeah, lifesteal.
I like that.
I like lifesteal.
This inner demon shit is so fucking complicated.
I...
The thing I...
I think like the one...
The one thing I don't like is...
It's just the inner demon.
Cause I'm...
I'm a little confused about what that is still.
I...
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha.
I'm a little...
I'm so confused...
About what he wants me to...
Do.
Cause it's like...
It's like...
The...
It's cause like the humans are also evil.
So like...
I shouldn't kill the humans.
Even if they're evil.
So like...
That's what confuses me the most.
Alright.
Well I killed him.
I did my job.
And then it punishes me for dying too much too.
Use it to...
You can start different.
Okay.
So now...
I should be able to...
Upgrade...
More stuff.
Okay.
I have...
I can technically unlock vitality.
Okay.
Cool.
And then...
I can lock more...
Okay.
I can't unlock vitality.
So...
We can do more Ungabunga then.
Okay.
If anything...
Ungabunga.
Can save me.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
If anything...
We'll just have more Ungabunga.
It's fine.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
Oh I don't have enough.
Sorry.
No.
Not enough Ungabunga.
Unfortunately.
Temper.
Yeah.
That's my...
My arm.
And then...
I reset my heals.
Did I grab the key?
Wait.
He's gone.
Where did he go?
Run?
Wait.
I didn't even get to talk to him.
The guy that was knocking on the door is also gone.
Oh.
I got the key.
Okay.
Nice.
Wait.
What happened to him?
Okay.
Oh.
Oh!
Are these like...
Extra bonuses?
Ha ha.
Goodbye.
Oh my god.
That's so...
Holy shit.
Okay.
I like crushed the puppy.
Oh my...
I'm not a bad person.
I swear.
I...
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh my god, I did not expect that.
He just stopped it.
What the, what is he?
Is he British?
Exactly!
That's what I'm saying!
I'm the bad person!
I have to fight my inner demons because I killed one or two monks.
And about the way to Doomwillow Beach...
Yeah, that's a very British... I was like, why is he British?
Somehow it caught fire and burned to the ground.
You can't get through now.
If you're headed to Doomwillow Beach, you'll have to find another route.
Mind if I ask why you came all the way here?
Have you heard the rumors about the Shu Sanctum?
Oh my god, right, he's from Hong Kong.
You're right!
They hidden all sorts of strange things upstairs.
Not that any of that interests me.
All I care about is finding medicine to heal my brother.
Oh, it's him!
We thought you were missing!
But who knew there'd be soldiers guarding the place?
They tossed me out before I could even explain myself.
They stand there like smug watchdogs.
Blocking anyone from getting close.
Matt, since I told you about the rumors...
Okay, I gotta grab the elixirs for him and save his brother.
With your skills, it should be a breeze, right?
That guy's just standing on top of a dead body.
Alright, we're gonna...
We're gonna steal the monks' treasure.
It's okay, they're evil monks.
Blow the whistle.
And I'll come to your aid.
Oh, shit!
The bone whistle.
How can...
You can blow while up to car navigate and then...
Okay, that's not too complicated.
Alright, we'll...
Where's the bone whistle?
Okay.
Alright, I can do that.
I can blow a whistle.
Alright, we're gonna test the whistle out.
Is it one time news?
Or like...
Can I use it multiple times?
Well, we'll...
We'll see.
Let's see.
Blessed by the primordial deity, the High Priest has procured healing at Glixxers.
His elephant brother will distribute it, one for each, so let no discourse arise in these trying times.
Okay.
Alright.
Uh...
Yoink!
Are you...
Here for the High Priest?
You'd be wiser just to leave.
The High Priest's ill.
Can't save anyone.
Look around you.
Everyone came for healing.
But now, they're all monsters.
Technically, there's nobody here.
Thankfully...
Because I killed them all.
That officer showed up right on time to defend us.
Or...
We'd all be dead.
He even warned us to avoid the Shu Sanctum.
But now...
He's suffering too.
All because he wanted to protect us.
Oh!
He's suffering from the Feathering.
And only the Imperial Court still remembers us.
Oh, I should...
Oh, is it like a summon?
I should save it for a boss fight?
If you're determined to go to the Shu Sanctum, take the long path around.
Here...
Take this medicine.
The High Priest said it might help with the Feathering.
I don't know if it'll work, but...
It has brought me some comfort.
Best to take it one day at a time.
Okay.
Nice!
Free stuff!
Okay, so...
I got...
What did he give me?
The Raven medicine?
Restores a small amount of HP.
Well, it's nice that like...
My heal...
My flask...
Uh...
Oh my god...
That arm...
Like, I don't even want to touch my own arm.
It's like...
Is that my arm?
Like, I'm like...
Oh my god...
That looks fucked up.
Like...
I'm just looking at my arm.
I'm like...
What the fuck is wrong with it?
Looks like I have like...
Like...
What is it called?
Leprosy.
Whoa.
Oh shit!
Oh wait, he's crazy!
Okay.
Okay!
What?!
What is that range?!
Never mind, you ruined it.
Oh my god!
They're so tanky!
Yeah, that gets a crazy range.
That...
That had like huge range and damage too.
I couldn't even process it.
I didn't think like he'd do that much to me.
Oh shit.
Whoops.
Almost went the wrong way.
I'll still look...
To be fair, I was still looking at my arm.
Like I...
The arm was like a huge deal to me.
To be fair.
I was like...
What the fuck is wrong with my arm?
Okay, um...
Okay, we'll try to do the arm shit again.
Okay, that's just a regular person.
So we gotta fight this guy.
Oh!
He was like...
You gotta take the long path.
And I...
Decided not to listen.
Like right now.
Okay, now I know.
Now I know why he was like...
You should take the long path.
He was just...
Like...
Holy...
Okay, wait.
No, I can kill him.
I might have to fight my inner demons.
But I can kill him.
How does this compare to Wukong?
Wukong was less souls-like.
This is...
More souls- This is more souls-like for sure.
I-I think I can- I think I can kill him.
I just have to definitely play a lot more careful.
Like I did like one-third the damage already.
Oh, is that Guan Yun's weapon?
I feel like my inner demon's gonna show up.
I...
I feel like she's gonna show up any moment.
Wait.
Oh, yeah.
No, she's here.
She's...
She's definitely here.
Oh, no.
She's guarding my runes, isn't she?
I feel like she's guarding it.
Oh, she's definitely here.
Oh, I know she's here.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
Okay.
That's right.
Swing!
Okay.
Oh, shit.
I need a heal though.
It's so slow.
The heals are so slow.
That's the only thing I don't like.
Okay, to be fair.
There was a lot, but...
Not a lot?
Wait, no.
That's not the right way.
There were some things I don't like, but...
I don't think the heals being really...
Okay.
I would say there's a lot.
I just don't like how slow the heals are.
Alright.
We have better armor now.
Where did I...
Okay, there.
Nice.
I got Ming armor.
That's right.
I'm her.
I'm you now.
Fuck it.
I'm fully you.
That's right.
Look at my drip.
How do I get that?
Oh, whoa.
Oh, cool.
Alright.
Okay, so I can only use...
Oh my god.
That's poison.
I just like walked right into it.
Okay.
That was so bad.
Yeah, I look fucking cool as hell now.
Wait, was this supposed to be the long way?
I assume like...
This was supposed to be the long way.
I mean, he wasn't that hard.
That's the thing.
That guy wasn't even that hard.
To be fair.
Where?
Did he have a cape?
I don't...
I can't equip anything else though.
Oh my god.
Please tell me there's a...
Shrine...
Anywhere?
No shrine?
Oh my god.
There's no shrine.
I have so many.
Mercury.
How's the game so far?
Oh, compass.
Yellow markers.
Shrines are yet to pay at...
Oh my...
Okay.
Okay, now...
I like how it tells me...
What...
What my compass means.
Okay.
Yellow is talk.
Red is...
Okay, now I understand the compass.
Okay, red equals shrine.
Okay, there's...
The person I have to talk to.
Oh, it's a safe place!
Oh!
It's a safe place!
Okay.
I made it.
I made it to the safe place.
Okay.
I guess it's time...
To level...
This...
Up?
Like...
This...
These, I don't really understand that much.
I don't really understand what this...
Okay.
Up...
Up, up, up, up...
This one is more complex.
This- This part of the skill tree...
I'm not like fully understanding.
Look, this is like...
I guess like magic?
I guess...
Oh, you guys can't read it.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, yeah.
Maybe I should try to be... Wait, let's look at...
Okay, this is awkward.
This is awkward, because I can't be left side doki.
I can't be left side doki for you guys.
We'll just get vitality, fuck it.
We'll just get vitality, guys.
Yeah.
Okay.
I could... You know what?
I could level up a lot, actually.
Because I have all of these.
Right?
Okay.
It's like, I assume these are like... I could freely use this.
And I have a lot of... Mercury now.
There's 200.
They give us a lot of Mercury.
Which I've noticed.
Because I have a lot of these.
And then...
Uh...
I guess I'll go with...
I don't need to do any blocking, though.
Okay, uh...
We'll do Endurance.
And then we'll use Strength.
Ungabunga.
I see, like, different abilities.
And I'm just, like...
Damage.
I'm just...
I'm just gonna do damage.
All right.
We'll talk to him.
Just call me with that whistle.
And I'll be at your beck and call.
All right.
Cool.
Can only be open with the Shoe Sanctum Key.
Hey!
Oh, it's him!
Oh!
Okay, this one's clearly better.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, is it?
Does it have a comparison?
It's so hard to tell.
Because there's no comparison for it.
So I can't...
Tell if it's...
Better.
Mine's plus one, too.
There's no...
Unless, like...
Oh, maybe they...
Okay, wait.
We should give him the...
Yeah, mine's plus one.
Okay, mine is the same, then.
You made it.
Now, that's a fine.
It took quite the effort to get this out from the treasure hoard under the Shoe Sanctum.
Dootanga always kept a sharp eye on it.
Since you've shown you're serious, I'll show you something rare, never seen by anyone else.
Oh?
Not to brag, but my stuff.
Rare grave goods plucked straight off their bodies.
Most folks don't live long enough to enjoy the spoils.
But you've got the guts and control to handle it.
I'm in a good mood today, so I'll show you some real treasure from the graves.
Consider it a gift from your new friend.
Hey, if you come across anything good, don't forget...
What does he give me, though?
Wait, what?
That's it?
Are you sure you don't want to have it?
The fuck is my... my cut?
I show you my ball, respond.
Like... what?
They didn't give me anything.
Silence.
Disciples.
Say no more.
The underground palace.
I should never have led you up there.
Lu Hong Liu.
Oh, whoops.
I like how, like, if I skip the dialogue, she'll go back to the place where I skipped it.
Which is nice.
Oh, she... he has new stuff to buy.
Oh, he does!
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean that earlier.
I didn't realize that, uh...
I didn't realize you had...
You had more dialogue.
I...
I didn't realize that, like, you giving me more stuff.
Sorry, buddy.
What treasures do you have for me today?
Let me make an assessment.
Oh.
Okay, what's this?
Okay, I have...
I have a copper jug.
Oh.
Yeah?
She was already married.
And had twins.
Oh.
But did that stop him?
Not in the slightest.
He was there daily.
When chaos erupted in town, Dootanga kidnapped her.
Left those poor kids without parents.
Oh my god!
What a cruel twist of fate.
That's so fucked up!
Just cause he couldn't, like, have it.
And then I get his fucking face?
Oh my...
That's crazy!
After he told me that story, he, like...
You can buy a fucking mask made out of skin.
Out of human skin!
Holy shit!
And eyes!
Oh my god!
That's crazy!
Wait, is mine...
Mine's blunt, right?
Made out of human eyes?
Let's take it.
Fuck it.
Let's buy it.
If you've got more than you need...
Now that's drip!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Yeah, but I don't use ma...
Okay, this is...
Yeah, it's blunt.
Okay.
Okay, it's...
That's more blunt than stab.
Okay, so...
I guess it's time to work...
Does that make it up for it?
I should...
Uh...
Not that good.
My friendship bracelet!
Ha ha ha ha!
Okay, what does it look like?
Oh, you can barely tell its eyes.
No fun.
Ha ha ha ha!
You can barely tell.
I like to see...
I like it when it's more noticeable.
Hello, Granny.
My son.
Is it really you?
Yeah, it's me.
Oh, Lynn.
You foolish boy.
I gave you this charm to protect you.
Oh, she's blind.
You're returning it to me.
I...
It's no good anymore.
Here, take this white stead.
New mom!
I beseeched our ancestors for this...
Some...
Time ago.
Offer it at their shrine.
And it'll ease your spirit to shield you from evil.
Oh, that's like a gift.
You joined those towers for that exorcism at the Lord Courtland, didn't you?
Yay!
My second mom!
Let's go!
If I collect all the moms...
Stealing from the blind!
That's a new low!
As for that Lu Hongyu...
She's become a man-eating fiend!
Do you even understand how much I worry for you?
If only official Bai was still alive...
That monster would've been dealt with long ago...
But...
Lu Hongyu has her father to thank for what she's become...
Yeah, fuck her!
Her father, back when he was the coroner...
Raised her on the flesh and bones of the dead!
No wonder she turned into such a creature!
I heard from the townest priest that she gnaws on some small, strange meat...
And no matter how she is, it's never finished!
Is she the half-naked bird lady in the trailer?
A white jade dumpling!
A cure for every illness, they say!
If only I could have a taste of it!
I'd be as healthy as ever!
No longer a burden to you, my dear child!
Of course!
I'm your new son!
That's me!
Stay here!
I'll pray to the gods to protect us!
Don't worry!
I'm technically him now!
His blood still stains the armor!
Alright, we gotta get the dumplings so I can cure her!
What the fuck was that?
Him?
Who dares disturb me?
It's me!
Your arms are feathered, yet, unlike those monsters, you remain sane enough to engage in conversation.
It's not identity theft if he's dead.
Today's sanity may be gone for the most.
That is like, 100% identity theft!
In the pasts, I wonder how much you still recall.
True!
Just as I thought.
You can hear them.
You wanna make the old lady sad?
I'm just trying to make...
I'm just trying to give him ho- give her hope.
Pulling you, Tua.
This is my inner demon.
A torment that's lingered far too long.
Defeated.
Oh, it will be the end of you.
Should your sanity...
Oh, nice!
I got more mercury.
I shall send you to the afterlife last.
First off, we're gonna make sure we're in her will.
Okay, guys.
Before we tell her the truth...
Just gotta make sure...
We tie all...
Tie all loose ends.
And then...
I'll tell her the truth.
Okay!
Her son never visited her.
I am a good son.
I literally visited her right after I killed her real son.
And she was like, Oh my god!
I haven't seen you in so long!
And I was like...
Yep!
Don't worry!
But I'm here now.
What did I get?
Just like...
I did more than...
Whatever the fuck her old son did.
Wait, is this a boss fight?
How did I just walk into...
Ha ha ha!
Oh, wait.
Wait, that's not a woman.
I was told that...
It was a lady.
How can you tell it's a lady?
How can you tell it's not a lady?
Ha ha ha!
Ha
ha ha!
I...
Yes!
He's the priest!
I told you!
I knew it!
It's the priest!
What the fuck?
He's just...
Like...
What do you want me to do?
Ha ha!
He's just jumping around.
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
Corrupted!
What does that mean?
Oh, it's just poison.
It's fine.
He's just jumping.
So it's like...
Jesus!
Okay, nevermind.
What the fuck?!
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
He just fucking...
Grabbed me like that.
That should be illegal.
Get grabbed.
I wish I could jump.
I miss...
I miss jumping.
You can check from...
Any additional content from...
Within.
Help.
Under the...
System...
Menu.
What will help me?
They're like...
Check the help button.
You'll need it.
I'm like...
They're like...
Just read it.
What?
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
Okay.
Nice.
Good.
Okay.
That's good.
Oh!
I forgot to use fire.
I did not expect her to be so fast though.
Okay.
Oh, come on.
Nice.
Okay.
Alright.
Like, I don't know...
Okay.
That's how you dodge that.
Nevermind.
Dude.
Are you...
Oh my god.
The stupid corruption.
Oh!
The stu...
Yeah.
The stupid corruption.
I didn't...
I've never seen that move before too.
Alright.
Let's...
I'll have to do the fire thing first.
Before I go in.
Okay.
That was for the identity theft.
Go in first.
And then...
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, it does so much damage.
Holy shit.
Okay.
He is definitely weak to fire.
Oh, I hate...
I hate that.
I hate that corruption.
I hate the corruption.
Oh my god.
Fucking stupid ass command grab.
I'm dead.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh yeah.
I'm so dead.
That takes so much...
Oh my god.
That takes so much damage.
Does I need more vitality?
That was bad timing.
If...
I don't know if it's like...
What I'm...
The skill...
I'm fucking up my skill tree.
But like...
They do so much damage.
For like...
The amount of...
HP I have.
Oh, I'm...
I'm...
Mad.
I'm mad now.
Okay.
At least I know I'm mad.
I need a...
No!
Ah!
I saw it too!
His command grab is like...
Sort of...
Bit...
Funky.
Jesus Christ.
Are you serious?
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
Back.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, I was panicking a little bit.
Cause I was like, where's dad?
And then...
Cause he was in his bed.
But I did have like...
Okay, so he has a lot of different types of...
He has a lot of dog beds scattered around the apartment.
Uh...
Well, he has like...
Three.
He has four.
But the fourth one...
He doesn't use.
Because it's...
I...
I don't know.
He doesn't...
He never uses the fourth one.
But like...
It's basically like a little house.
It's like a little house, basically.
So it's like a little...
Cave bed.
But he never uses it.
So I was like, where is he?
And then like...
I...
I was like...
Crouched down.
And I saw him in the little cave bed.
And I was like, what the fuck?
He has a lot of options.
Yeah.
I was like, where is he?
And then I like...
Crouched down to find him.
How the fuck did I get like a...
Like...
I don't know.
What was it?
Like...
Um...
A stagger?
Is it like...
Fucking...
I don't even know how I got it earlier.
What?!
That should not have hit me!
Oh...
Me angy.
All right.
I'm...
I'm locking in.
I'm locking in now.
Your power is increased, but so has the damage...
Oh, I'm a...
I'm actually angry.
I...
She's angry too now!
I swear to God, if my inner demon shows up...
I swear...
Is it interesting though!
Like, if...
The more times you die, the more damage you do!
Like, that's also...
Oh my God!
I don't know, this one...
This is...
Oh my God!
I don't know...
This one...
Guess not...
Is not...
Like...
Okay, now I'm locked in.
Now I'm...
Okay, he might have just perfected me, but I'm locked in now.
Bro is doing a no-hit challenge.
I don't know if I'm under level or not.
That's an issue too.
I could be under level.
I do have...
I do have like one more of this, but... Wait, can I call?
Oh my god, I'm so dumb.
Get over here.
It's time.
That's right.
Get him.
It's time.
I brought it 2v1.
That's right.
It's 2v1 time.
No one said I couldn't do it.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I know.
He's fucking dead.
That's right.
2v1.
That's all I needed.
I just needed a second guy.
That's... That's cheating.
I'm sorry.
He's okay.
There we go.
That's all.
Oh yes, the one point.
I'm gonna work smarter, not harder.
I got the Echo of Zuu.
What is that?
What did I get?
Wait.
This is like a magic build.
Oh, I got magic.
I feel like, is magic that strong?
Oh, magic must be really strong.
Hmm.
Oh well.
I'm holding back the whole time.
I was like, I know what to do.
That's it.
I'm calling my crew.
I'm calling the crew over.
Now, now I'm mad.
Yeah, that boss did not last 10 seconds.
Okay, wait.
Who do I talk to now that I beat his ass?
Not the crew.
What a shock.
I didn't expect the old priest to turn into a monster.
No wonder the soldiers were stationed there.
Good thing I kept up my training.
Yeah, good thing I had a meat shield.
You're not quite skilled yourself.
Disrespected the one we won.
Yeah, here you go.
So it happened to fall into your possession.
This thing looks peculiar.
Wait, I had armor with no poison.
Oops.
Look, I had to, I had to get into the old woman's will.
Okay?
You'll have it.
I must return to reverend temple to save my mother.
If you ever need anything, you know where to find me.
Cool.
By whatever means necessary, I had to get into the will.
Oh, I'm, I'm very angry.
They're like, you can't, you can't do anymore.
You're too angry.
All right, let's scream.
Oh my god, my dreams are red now.
Oh my god, holy shit.
Oh, that's not good.
I'm having very angry dreams.
I'm letting out my, my anger now too.
Oh shit, secret tunnel.
Why is there blood in my secret tunnel?
Why is there?
Who fucking died here?
Oh my god, wait, a lot of people died here.
Wait, this is a scary secret tunnel.
How did I?
Oh my god, it's all poison.
It's all poison.
Oops, all poison.
Wait, what?
Oh, we have to push in, denying us, and try to develop them to them.
Reveal his heretical ways for all the seed.
I don't use spells.
Oh, it's like...
Oh, yay, it's a little brighter now.
Did not grab magic?
Oh, it's not had magic on me.
What the fuck?
What's that one guy in particular?
Look, there's some monks there.
Spin!
That's right.
I'm already angry anyway.
No consequences.
My inner demons is chasing me.
Who's talking?
From the shoe sanctum.
These guys?
The hood stopped up above.
The other below.
A hood.
The one downstairs.
It's already dead.
Wait, are these the guys talking?
How come the other guy sounds like Gollum, and then...
Like, wait.
So like, that's a choice?
Like, apparently, yes.
It's fine.
Because the other guy...
The fucking other guy merchant sounds like...
Sounds like Gollum, and these guys are just like regular guys.
He's the only one that's committed to the bit.
All right.
Let's grab this real quick.
Maybe I can...
Okay.
Never mind.
It doesn't...
Oh, I like how...
Oh, corruption is poison.
I see.
Maybe I should have more poison resistance today.
I'm committed to.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
All right.
Let's go.
Let's dream.
Let's go to my mad dream.
Yeah.
I'm so angry.
What the fuck?
Oh, it's just a...
It's just a guy.
It's just him.
Okay.
No, there's a mineshaft too?
Oh my god.
No.
No, that's the shortcut.
I can never escape them.
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
You?
Jesus Christ.
And then I get shot.
In the middle of trying to heal.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Get out.
No one likes you.
Oh.
Ugh.
Oh, that does not do a lot.
Why are you backing away?
Oh my god.
That's poison.
Oh, fuck.
Oh my god.
And it's complete.
I can never escape it.
We won't escape.
There's double poison?
Oh, and it...
Oh.
Okay.
That's stronger poison.
Oh.
Oh my god, there's the feathered men.
Oh wait, they're both feathered.
Oh, that means killing them won't be a crime!
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, am I... No, I'm still fucking mad.
Gotta make sure I don't touch the poison.
Oh!
What the fuck?!
Thank god, he missed!
Oh my god, when I don't have messages to tell me about ambushes, it's a whole new experience.
Oh, thank god.
This actually is a whole different experience when I don't have, like, the messages to tell me about the ambushes.
Alright, up I go.
Jesus Christ, that's a long ladder.
Up, up, up!
Weeeeeeeeee!
Oh.
Okay, to be fair, that rock then did really well.
I swear... Oh my god, it's him.
It's a gunman.
Alright.
Okay.
I wanna use one of the other spells.
I'm not running right now because I'm scared.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, that's good that I did run.
I was like, I'm scared about what flies ahead.
Wait, what's this?
Wait.
Oh!
Guys.
Goodbye.
Wait, what?
Wait.
What?
Oh my god, I guess.
Never mind.
No goodbye.
How?
How did it escape?
I'm sweating it.
Yes, goodbye.
I... Oh my god.
What the fuck am I looking at?
Holy... shit.
That's a core weapon.
Oh my god!
No, no, no, no...
No, not ultra poison!
I refuse to get ultra poison!
Oh my god.
Do I have to go that way?
Is there another way I can go?
I'm wondering if I had to... Okay, drop down from here.
I broke my fucking chins, I guess.
I...
Alright, cool.
What?!
Okay, that's like such a short... that's such a short time.
This is the message telling you about the next ambush.
Next, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Like, it felt like I could go through it, but I guess my dumpy was too thick.
I guess my dumpy was just a little too thick.
Oh well.
Oh fucking well.
Is it here that dropped me down?
Yeah, it was.
Okay, I'm gonna see if I can get out of here.
Yeah, I'm just gonna run past everything.
Like, fuck this.
Oh my god, off of your head.
I'm just gonna run past everything.
Okay, nice.
Invincibility frames.
That's good.
Just slowly climb up.
It's okay, they don't have hands to climb up ladders.
At the moment, I don't really know how I feel about this game.
I think, like, my only, um...
The one thing I don't really...
That I don't like is just the slow heals.
The slow heals and...
Okay, I'm gonna fucking chop this fucking...
That's right.
Oh my god, he has a little dumpy too.
What does the ban...
Oh, Bamboo Shooters for upgrading.
Like, I have to drop here though.
Heals are very slow.
Oh my god, my inner demon!
My inner demon!
Oh my god.
She's so mad.
Oh my god, my inner demon's here.
Maybe she'll get tired.
Guys, do you think my inner demon will get tired?
Defeat my inner demon, Toki.
Holy shit, she's so...
Why is she so strong?
Compared to me!
Okay, it's fine.
Okay, I stun-locked her.
Let's go.
I actually stun-locked her into the fucking corner.
We're playing fighting games now.
But she's so tanky.
She was so fucking tanky.
At least, like, she brought my...
My mercury closer to me.
That's nice.
My inner demon defeated.
Are you serious?
Like, you whore!
I'm fucking kicking a ladder!
I get shot!
Like, what's wrong with you?
Wait, I'm back here.
I'm back at the shortcut.
Where the fuck am I supposed to go?
It doesn't work yet.
What?
Yeah, it's a shortcut.
So, is there another pathway up here?
There's nothing here.
Oh my god, I hate...
Oh, the...
Those guys...
I...
Calm down.
Ooh...
Yes, that was bullshit.
That was very extremely bullshit.
No.
Because there's nothing...
Nowhere to go from there.
Is there...?
Feels like there's nothing there.
Okay, that's good.
That...
That's so much damage.
I hate them so much.
I hate these...
I hate these guys so much.
And they can also grab...
Crap.
They were so hungry.
Yeah, the...
Hmm?
I'm so confused on like...
Hmm...
I'm very confused.
Cause it's like...
I went everywhere.
Did I not?
Did I not go everywhere?
Cause I don't think I have to fight that.
That's the thing.
I'm pretty sure I don't have to fight that.
I mean, I could cheese it like this.
I could literally cheese it with magic.
Yeah, this is like...
Oh my god.
They literally give me blight too.
I'm...
I'm trying.
Do I have to chop these?
No.
Okay.
No, I will never swap off my armor.
I...
I am her son.
Okay, I'm gonna cheese this.
Oh shit, you fucker.
Okay, nice.
Wait, what?
Oh, they're feathered too.
Nice.
OMG, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh!
Reading.
It's my dorkable cameoshi, technically.
But you make my day every day, Doki.
Love your dork keeping you.
We love you a bit.
You have no idea how much you mean to me personally.
Thank you again for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Oh, you have a great rest of your day.
Anyone, you've been enjoying the stream.
Okay, wait, I can infinitely farm this.
No, wait.
There you go.
No!
You know what I'm calling it.
I...
That's the end of today's stream.
That's...
I'm calling it here.
I mean...
Put a lot longer than I expected to.
Um...
Honest opinion.
It is...
A lot slower...
Than...
Than what I'm used to.
Uh...
It is...
A lot slower than what I'm used to.
When it comes to that...
I guess like...
Cause I've been playing Alden Ring for like...
How many weeks now?
Um...
And...
Uh...
Mmm...
The bosses...
Definitely feel...
Uh...
Feel...
How do I say?
It's a little hard to telegraph...
Their moves...
For now.
But I think it's cause like...
I'm not used to their...
Combat style.
I think if I get more used to...
Their combat style...
Then it'll be easier to read.
But they are...
They are...
I would say...
The moment the boss fights...
Uh...
Like the moment you realize like...
You know...
The moment it clicks...
It gets easier.
Because when I was fighting the guy...
You know...
When I was fighting this...
The...
The mom's son...
Um...
It like clicked.
And then I realized how to...
Do the fights.
Yeah, they move in very unique ways.
Uh...
The movement style for it.
Um...
Yeah, it is very overwhelming.
There's so many like...
Items...
Mechanics...
Weapons...
Skill tree...
And...
Every...
There's a lot.
There's a lot of like...
Stuff you need to do for the skill tree and everything.
And I'm pretty sure I'm doing the skill tree wrong.
I...
Yeah...
I'm pretty sure...
I'm doing the skill tree wrong.
So...
I think that's why I was like...
Struggling a little bit.
Um...
There is a lot of information coming in.
So I was super overwhelmed at first.
Uh...
Yeah, I was like...
Rotter-dogging the skill tree.
I was just like...
I read like...
The...
The hard one was the madness.
I think the madness was the hardest thing to keep up with.
Because it's like...
I like...
I...
I don't understand.
Because like...
The skill tree also...
The skill tree also correlates with madness stuff as well.
And so like...
Because in the skill tree...
You guys weren't able to read it.
But like...
It's like...
Oh, if you're...
If you're above the madness level...
You do more damage if you unlock this and stuff like that.
So like...
Yeah, it's definitely very overwhelming.
So then you can be like...
I guess you can like...
Force yourself to keep dying over and over again.
To have more damage.
Um...
Just so you can...
Go in with more...
Like...
So you can go in with more madness.
So you can have more damage when you're fighting certain enemies.
So like...
I can see like...
Those types of strats...
Coming in.
But it definitely is a game where you guys have to try it yourself.
For sure.
Because for me...
I...
I don't know.
I don't know about...
Do a part 2 right away.
Maybe later on down...
Later...
Later on.
Because right now...
I do want to finish...
I do want to like...
Complete the...
Elder Ring goal.
The charity goal for Elder Ring first.
Before we go back to...
Uh...
Fallen...
Fallen Feathers.
Um...
And then maybe by then...
Like...
People will develop the meta for this game.
Because like...
I...
I sort of don't know what I'm doing right now.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
I...
I def...
Okay, no.
Not sorry.
I definitely don't know what I'm doing right now.
Ha ha ha ha!
Yeah.
I...
I'm just like...
Definitely a lot more confused.
Uh...
Cause I feel like I'm...
I just feel like I'm upgrading my skill tree wrong.
I am winning my fights.
But like...
I...
I don't know.
I feel like...
I'm not understanding the skill tree as much as I should be.
Or the madness shit.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Um...
Uh...
I might continue it in the future.
I might continue it.
Um...
I do want to finish Elden Ring first before I...
Do a part two of this.
Uh...
But yeah.
I honestly...
Encourage you guys to check it out yourself.
It was interesting for you guys.
Uh...
Not sponsored by the way.
They just gave me a free key.
Ha ha ha ha!
But if you enjoyed Souls-like...
If you really enjoyed Souls-like...
You might enjoy this.
It is slower though.
It is slower than Elden Ring...
And Bloodborne.
Um...
But apparently it's like Dark Souls 1.
So if you like Dark Souls 1, then you might like this.
Uh...
Yeah!
Um...
I'm gonna call it here.
I just have a lot of work to do.
So I'm just gonna call it here.
Um...
But I hope you guys...
Had a great time watching.
Um...
Like I said...
Please support...
Uh...
All the...
Girls...
Plus one guy.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Um...
After everything that happened.
Minna is having her five year anniversary.
And like I said...
There is a collab going on...
For those that...
For the girls that were supposed to debut...
In...
Bishoujo.
And...
Um...
Yeah!
Please support all of them.
Not just those girls.
But like...
Um...
Everyone that was in Bishoujo.
Like the...
The original...
The original members.
The ones that left earlier.
Um...
And...
The staff as well.
But yeah.
Um...
They really do deserve...
The love and support.
And I hope...
Um...
I hope they...
Find their footing.
And...
Get...
Um...
All that love and support from their communities.
And...
Everyone around them.
Hey guys!
Together move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you...
Except for me...
Head to bed!
Cause...
You deserve it!
I'll see you guys...
Uh...
See you guys next time everyone!
Bye guys!
Bye!
Also donate to charity!
Donate to the Immune Deficiency Foundation.
That's on Silify!
Um...
Yeah...
I'll give a link to it.
Cause...
You know...
Why not?
I mean...
Hit...
I can't believe it hit a million dollars!
I'm...
So happy!
I'm so happy and proud of everybody!
Um...
Cause what...
Everybody raised that in like...
What?
Two to three days?
Crazy!
Absolutely insane!
Um...
It's really cool to see.
Hey guys!
I'll see you guys later...
Later everyone!
Bye guys!
Bye!
Also buy my merch too!
I mean...
Okay...
Actually that's weird to say.
After I said...
Donate to charity!
But also like...
Like...
Buy my merch!
But...
Sorry!
It was a reflective...
Reflexive thing, you know?
At the end where I was like...
Buy my merch!
Uh...
But...
You know...
It's kinda weird!
Sorry!
I just got so used to saying it!
Anyways...
I'll see you guys later!
Bye guys!